Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und äh das hier ist die hundertsiebte Ausgabe vom 16. November.
2022 und ähm nachdem ich zuletzt ja mit John auf
Die Brexit-Situation geschaut habe, mal wieder, wollen wir jetzt natürlich auch mal wieder auf die Ukraine-Situation schauen. Dazu begrüße ich natürlich Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Genau, denn wir haben jetzt dann auch schon wieder gut einen Monat nicht äh Updates geliefert. Das mag äh mittlerweile viel erscheinen, weil dann ist dann doch einiges passiert. Aber wir hatten dann auch erstmal so eine kleine Urlaubsphase.
Ähm in der es äh ja nur ums Beobachten und uns sammeln ging.
Und jetzt ähm jetzt stehen wir da und äh haben eigentlich schon wieder fast viel zu viel zu ähm berichten. Mhm.
Ich würde gerne anfangen.
Da wo wir zuletzt aufgehört haben, weil als wir die Sendung dann äh die letzte aufgenommen haben war ja der Anschlag auf die Krimbrücke gerade erst einige Tage her, ne, also,
Wir haben am 12. Oktober veröffentlicht und wenn ich mich jetzt richtig erinnere war der Anschlag auf die,
Brücke am wann war das? Irgendwie so am achten oder neunten, ne.
Und ähm jetzt.
Könnte man sozusagen noch mal draufblicken und sagen, äh war denn das, was wir damals dachten, was dort passiert ist, äh auch tatsächlich das, was äh passiert ist. Wir hatten uns ja eigentlich relativ klar auf diese LKW.
Variante festgelegt und ich hab auch so den Eindruck seitdem hat sich da auch nichts anderes wirkliches äh ergeben.
Das scheint sich so weitgehend
bestätigt äh zu haben, dass das wahrscheinlich eine Aktion, ja, des ukrainischen Geheimdienstes äh war, der dann den LKW auf die Brücke mit einer Bombe oder mit mehreren Bomben.
Gebracht hat und so es zu den Zerstörungen gekommen ist.
Macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob der Schaden letztlich dann doch noch ein bisschen größer war als zuerst vermutet, ne? Also vielleicht zur Erinnerung. Dieser LKW ist auf dieser Brücke explodiert. Daraufhin sind zwei, drei ähm Bahnsegmente.
Der Brücke, also der Straße, des Straßenteils der Brücke ähm eingestürzt
davon gibt's zwei Fahrspuren, das heißt, die andere Fahrspur, die ist nicht eingestürzt, war aber wohl auch so weit mitbeschädigt worden, dass ähm auch große Trucks dort immer noch nicht fahren.
Habe ich jetzt noch nichts gehört, dass sich das groß geändert haben soll, sprich der ganze Verkehr musste dann auf Fähren aus äh weichen.
Was natürlich den ganzen Güterverkehr extrem äh beeinträchtigt. Aber auch diese.
Eisenbahnbrücke, die ja neben dieser Straßenbrücke verläuft und die ja nur mittelbar betroffen war.
Wo dann dieser Zug drauf stand, ja, der mit Diesel beladen war, die durch die Explosion, also durch die.
Ganzen Debri, also diese ganzen kleinen Teile, die da losgescheuert äh losgeschleudert werden bei so einer Explosion. Offenbar.
Dafür gesorgt haben, dass dass diese Tanks auch wegschlagen und dann auch gebrannt haben, aber nicht explodiert sind. Und das hat dann relativ lange gebrannt und hat wohl eine ganze Menge Hitze erzeugt und das hat schon dazu geführt, dass auch diese Bahnlinie.
So nicht mehr benutzbar ist. Alle haben irgendwie damit gerechnet so, naja okay, gut, dann reparieren sie da die Schienen und dann, dann, dann funktioniert das auch wieder. Aber offensichtlich scheint.
Der Mensch so stark zu sein, dass auch größere Züge dort immer noch nicht äh fahren können. Zumindest jetzt keine, die irgendwelche Panzer transportieren.
Oder hast du da irgendwas anderes mitbekommen, was äh naheliegend würde, dass das sich in einem besseren Zustand befindet.
Nee, es sieht in der Tat so aus, ja, dass.
Die Einschränkungen äh die du geschildert hast im Zugverkehr wie auch im LKW-Verkehr weiterhin.
Andauern und auch noch eine Weile andauern. Äh
haben jetzt zumindest ein äh so ein so ein Fahrbahnstück jetzt in
Position gebracht, also auf Schiffe verladen, das ist das letzte, was ich jetzt gesehen habe, dass sie da irgendwie jetzt äh zumindest ein Stück Fahrbahn.
Dabei sind, anzutransportieren.
Ja das ist auch schon eingesetzt. Also das eine, das eine Segment ist schon ausgetauscht,
bleiben halt noch zwei andere und was sonst noch an Reparaturen zu machen ist, also könnte sein, dass quasi, wenn sie die Geschwindigkeit beibehalten zumindest die Straße dann bald wieder befahrbar ist, aber das.
Ansonsten haben sie aber gesagt, dass die Reparaturen insgesamt bis Juli 2023 andauern sollen. Und das ist natürlich schon ein hartes Stück.
Also das ähm klingt nach sehr viel mehr Schaden und logistischen Problemen, als man jetzt vielleicht am Anfang hätte vermuten können.
Warum ist das überhaupt alles so ein Problem? Ich weiß gar nicht, inwiefern wir da drauf eingegangen sind, aber.
Diese ganze äh Situation dort verschärft sich natürlich jetzt auch durch den nahenden Herbst und Winter. Also grad diese da, diese.
Bereich, der von dieser Brücke überfahren wird, der ist halt.
Dafür bekannt im Winter auch ziemlich rau zu sein. Da ist also äh einerseits eine Menge Seegang, teilweise auch Eisschollen, die da lang äh.
Lang treiben und äh den Fährverkehr auch teilweise komplett zum Erliegen zu bringen. Also kann sogar sein, dass die logistischen Probleme, die sie da jetzt ohnehin schon haben, auch was die Reparatur betrifft noch.
Schwerer ausfallen äh können als als als jetzt schon, ne.
Natürlich auch sein, dass sich da irgendwas beschleunigt oder als einfacher herausstellt. So oder so seit vier Wochen kann die Verbindung zwischen Russland und Krim, die dort neu gebaut worden ist.
Nicht mehr genutzt werden, sowohl zur militärischen Belieferung der ganzen Kriegsgebiete, aber auch der ganzen.
Versorgung der Krim, die ja einfach, da sie ja nun vom Norden nicht gerade mit irgendwas beliefert wird, alle ihre Güterverbrauchsgüter Lebensmittel vor allem halt aus Russland erhält.
Ja und das äh könnte natürlich innerhalb der Krim auch für Probleme sorgen und habe jetzt
nicht von riesigen Fluchtströmen gehört, aber ich denke mal, wenn's da irgendeine Bewegung gibt, dann halt eher in Richtung Russland, zumal sich ja die Gesamtsituation,
auch weiter verschärft, wie wir gleich noch erläutern werden. Ja, also dort gibt's äh viele Kilometer LKW-Stau.
Und ähm insgesamt ist die Situation dieser Krimbrücke nicht gut für die Russen und man kann sagen, das war einfach mal ein.
Super, super, super erfolgreicher äh Akt, der.
Ukrainischen Special Forces oder wer auch immer da äh seine Finger mit im Spiel gehabt hat. Das war einfach gnadenlos gut geplant, vorbereitet und durchgeführt und super effektiv. Während alle die ganze Zeit darüber gerätselt haben, wir ja auch.
Was man so gegen diese Krimmbrücke tun kann und immer so hm na ja okay, da kannst du viel Raketen draufschmeißen, aber es wird wahrscheinlich nicht so viel bringen so. Da waren die dann schon wieder drei Schritte weiter. Einfach gesagt.
Einfach LKW voll ruffahren bam läuft schon.
Ja und in und ein weiteres Problem diskutiert hatten, ist, dass natürlich äh
extremen Aufwand auch treiben müssen, wenn sie wieder LKW da drauflassen, dass sich das nicht nicht wiederholt. So und das kann mit einem Grund sein
auch warum.
Sie bisher da äh den LKW-Verkehr noch äh äh eingeschränkt äh haben, weil sie nicht so richtig wissen, wie sie das mit der Sicherheitsüberprüfung machen sollen.
Mhm. Ja, das kommt noch dazu, weil es ist natürlich durchaus sein kann, dass äh Ukraine das nochmal probiert.
Auch wenn sie vielleicht schon wieder ganz andere Sachen ersinnen, aber sie wissen zumindest, dass Bedrohungspotential ist da und.
Vielleicht läuft das dann alles nicht so flüssig, wie sie sich das gewünscht haben. Ja, ja, das kann schon sein.
Und das Problem alleine ist dann auch die Durchleuchtungsstation erstmal in Gefahr äh sind. So, also müssen dann richtig Aufwand.
Treiben mit irgendwie vor Kontrolle und Entladen und so, um wirklich sicher zu gehen, dass da nicht nochmal eine Bombe mitgeschickt.
Erstmal in der Vorkontrolle losgeht, nur um die kaputt zu machen, um danach nochmal die Brücke kaputt zu machen. Ja, ja.
Das ist sozusagen die unangenehme Bedrohungssituation, dass sie halt äh ja äh sagen Vorkontrollen brauchen, um die Hauptkontrolle zu schützen und äh ja.
Totaler Terror. Ja gut ähm so viel vielleicht zur äh Krimbrücke. Und dann ähm
Am besten mal gleich hier den Elefanten im im Raum, denn natürlich, ihr werdet es alle gehört haben, die große Nachricht ist
die Belagerung der Stadt durch die ukrainischen Truppen letztlich erfolgreich gewesen ist und Russland angekündigt hat, sich
von diesem Gelände zurückzuziehen und das haben sie mittlerweile auch getan, sodass also weitere viele tausend Quadratkilometer Land, die eins von Russland erobert wurden, wieder zurückerobert werden konnten.
Und das Ganze ist vor allem auch relativ unblutig abgelaufen.
Was ist passiert? Also vielleicht noch mal so zur Ausgangssituation dieser ganze Bereich ist ja einer der ersten
überhaupt von Russland besetzt wurde. Das ging am Anfang des Krieges relativ schnell und ich glaube, da sind auch die ein oder anderen
gerollt in der ukrainischen Armee, weil das war natürlich ein großes Versagen. Ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt die Bedrohung im Süden so nicht gekannt hätte.
Und äh dieser Übergang von der Krim äh nach.
Ist ja jetzt auch ein Problem bei der Eroberung, das sind ja im Prinzip nur zwei Straßen, die dort von Süden nach Norden führen.
Ihn irgendwie nicht gelungen hier entsprechenden Widerstand äh entgegenzusetzen, nicht nur um das Eindringen überhaupt äh nach äh Fresshon, also die.
Ob Lars zu verhindern, sondern dann eben auch äh nicht in der Lage waren, das übertreten
russischen Truppen über die zwei Brücken, nämlich eben die bei dem Staudamm und eben die Antonowski-Brücke direkt bei der Stadt.
Äh das irgendwie zu verhindern und das Ergebnis war, dass die Russen halt drauf und dran waren.
Ins Land reinzustürmen, die Stadt Nikolaif anzugreifen und auch noch ein bisschen äh weiter nach Norden. Also sie sind ja im Prinzip von diesem
äh Fluss sind sie ähm bis zu 134 Kilometer ins Land
ähm vorgedrungen und haben also versucht oben
diesen äh anderen Teilfluss, der dort ist. Das sind Namen, ich immer vergesse Bug heißt der, glaube ich, äh den irgendwie zu umrunden, um von dort einen Landweg nach äh Odessa.
Einschlagen zu können. Das konnte dann aber verhindert werden. Das wurde dann eben zurückgeschlagen und deswegen haben wir jetzt seit einem halben Jahr diese Situation gehabt, dass eben da so ein ja ein Teil.
Ähm ab diesem Fluss äh ins Land hinein von ähm den Russen gehalten wurde, aber dann eben die
Ukrainer so eine Verteidigungslinie äh haben aufbauen können. Also von Gengershof für so vierzig Kilometer ins Land und das Ganze eben über
'ne 'ne Breite von um die gut 150 Kilometern.
So und so war das dann eben alles eingefroren und dann gab's ja diese ersten Angriffe. Wir erinnern uns noch kurz bevor dann die eigentliche Offensive wiederum im Osten, in Rakif losging, die ja so erfolgreich war
gab's ja erstmal Angriffe so und zwar auf breiter Front und das hat ja dann auch die Russen dazu gebracht
die ganzen Truppen dort in zu verstärken.
Und sich selber im Osten wiederum zu schwächen, aber letzten Endes ist es nie so richtig viel passiert. Es gab hier so ein bisschen paar Vorstöße, da so ein paar kleine Kämpfe, ein paar Brückenköpfe, das ging dann auch hin und her und die
einzelne Orte, die dann gewonnen werden konnten, die wechselten auch mehrfach den Besitzer, aber so im Großen und Ganzen passiert da halt eigentlich gar nichts. Außer, dass natürlich dann,
durch das äh Verwenden dieser Präzisionsartillerie.
Also andere,
Systeme, also alles was so die Europäer und die Amerikaner geliefert haben, was einfach über große Distanzen extrem präzise Bomben abwerfen kann. Das wurde dann eben genutzt, einerseits, um eben diese ganzen Command und Control Posts ähm
Im Süden zu zerstören, Munitionslager natürlich zu zerstören, also überhaupt diese gesamte logistische Kette zu durchlöchern und zusätzlich eben auch noch diese Brücken
außer Betrieb zu nehmen. Haben wir auch mehrfach drüber gesprochen. Die waren auch gut durch Löcher. Das sieht man jetzt auch,
Auf frischen Fotos. Jetzt konnte man da ja mit Drohnen rüberfliegen, um mal zu gucken, was da überhaupt passiert ist.
Schon äh atemberaubend, wie äh präzise dort mit diesen Artillerie.
Munitionen, die halt was weiß ich, 50 bis 80 Kilometer weit losgeschossen wurden.
Da wirklich so eine so eine Reißverschlusslinie quer über diese Brücke, beide Brücken rübergezogen wurde, was eben dann dazu geführt hat, dass man da einfach mit so einem 12 Tonnen Panzer einfach nicht mehr rüberfahren kann.
Na ja, so und das hat natürlich dann die Situation dahingehend verschlechtert, dass dort 20tausend oder was weiß ich, wie viel es am Ende äh waren, Soldaten stationiert sind, die permanent.
Nahrungsmitteln versorgt werden müssen und natürlich auch noch mit äh Munition und mit Diesel und mit was nicht allem. Und das Ganze musste.
Mit Fähren gemacht werden.
Das war dann halt einfach irgendwann nicht mehr haltbar. So und das ist auch den Russen klar geworden und irgendwann war dann auch der politische Wunsch, die Stadt unbedingt zu halten, nicht mehr stark genug, um.
Militärische Realität zu ignorieren und dann.
Gab's ja dann nochmal einen Wechsel an der Führung des russischen Militärs. Es gibt jetzt diesen neuen Chef, der jetzt erstmalig für die gesamte Operation zuständig ist, wie heißt der Soro Wikin oder so.
Und ähm ja und der war im Prinzip als äh seine erste Amtshandlung ist im Prinzip gewesen, hier diesen Rückzug einzuleiten.
Fand dann auch statt über einen längeren Zeitraum.
Gab dann wieder viele Leute, die jetzt vielleicht die Situation nicht so direkt verfolgen, ja, die sich dann so wundern so, warum geht denn das auf einmal so schnell und so kampflos.
War es eben nicht, dass da die Stellung schwach gewesen wären und ähm.
Die äh Ukraine hätte jetzt äh die Russen so übertöpelt, wie das eben in äh Rakif in der Region Rakif gewesen ist, sondern hier war ja relativ klar, dass die Präsenz schon groß ist und die Russen haben sich da auch tief wieder in neue Verteidigungslinien eingegraben.
Allerdings in so einem zehn, 14tägigen Prozess.
Eigentlich erstmal so ihre ganzen Kommandanten, ihre ganzen Führungskräfte, diese ganzen installierten, administrativen Leute, die da diese Städte hätten fahren sollen. Die wurden irgendwie alle rausgeholt, die Lehrer.
Ähm und äh außerdem auch noch wohl ein Großteil ihrer besser ausgebildeten Soldaten
und die Stellungen wurden dann eben wiederum mit äh den also mit den mobilisierten Russen befüllt, damit da irgendwie jemand drin rumsaß, der äh
dann auch einfach abgeschossen werden konnte, dass äh hat die Russen ja nicht so sehr interessiert.
Und zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt gab's dann eben den Befehl, okay, ziehen wir uns auch komplett zurück. Das haben die sich wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anders vorgestellt.
So wie die ganzen Verteidigungslinien angelegt waren macht es so den Eindruck, als ob die Russen sich das eher.
So gedacht haben, dass man die Ukrainer.
Erst mit größeren Verlusten immer wieder Schritt für Schritt Linie für Linie äh vordringen lässt.
Ja, also man greift irgendwie in eine eine Verteidigungslinie an, wo dann halt Leute in irgendwelchen Gräben sind, die wehren sich so ein bisschen,
ähm muss die Ukraine wieder zurück, dann macht man vielleicht mal eine kleine Gegenoffensive. Also so ein so ein dieses übliche Hin und Her, was in der Regel sehr verlustreich ist.
Hat sich so ein bisschen auf den auf den auf die Ostregion eingefahren aber das wurde dann von der Ukraine zu dem Zeitpunkt wo klar war, dass der Großteil der Truppen sowieso jetzt schon abzieht,
glaube ich dadurch umgangen, indem sie einfach auf breiter Front überall angegriffen haben und äh dadurch sehr schnell Lücken gefunden haben und einfach diese ganzen Verteidigungslinien umfahren konnten.
Also auf jeden Fall ist es den Russen nicht gelungen, sagen.
Dass sich da allzu teuer äh zu verkaufen
immer gerne so Parallelen mit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg gezogen, was immer ein bisschen schwierig ist, aber nichtdestotrotz der Fall, der nun auch derselben Gegenstand, aber es wurde halt auch immer so ein
manchmal so ein bisschen mit Stalingrad verglichen, so auch so eine größere Stadt mit dem Rücken zum Fluss quasi äh nur das diesmal
ähm die Russen halt äh ja ähm das Ganze mehr oder weniger kampflos aufgegeben haben statt
jetzt im Häuserkampf bis zum letzten Blutstropfen äh zu verteidigen. Also ganz so wichtig scheint dann dieser russische Boden dann doch nicht zu sein, dass man jetzt.
Irgendwie dann ja ähm äh.
Da jetzt äh wirklich drum kämpfen würde,
so dann hat die Ukraine äh quasi ihren Boden, äh den sie da verteidigt hat, äh den den musste den mussten die Russen teuer erkaufen
äh so jeden jeden Meter äh den den sie nach erobert hatten im im Sommer und äh ja.
Relativ billig wieder abgeben.
Ja und das das war jetzt jetzt nicht so. Da haben waren die
Ukraine einfach ein bisschen cleverer und haben sich da jetzt nicht verausgabt, sondern im Prinzip auf der einen Seite Druck gemacht. Also so ist jetzt nicht so, das das ist jetzt das ist jetzt da freiwillig abgezogen werden die Russen. Kann man jetzt auch nicht nicht
nicht sagen, sondern das hat natürlich ein ganz klares mit
dem Druck und den Verlusten äh zu tun äh und mit den Kampfhandlungen, die dort.
Permanent stattfanden äh so ohne die wären sie wären sie halt nicht gegangen, aber ja aber die Ukrainer,
Haben dann eben ganz klar äh sich nicht drauf eingelassen jetzt.
Allzu große Verlustreiche äh Angriffschlachten zu führen, sondern eben immer
geguckt, geguckt, geguckt und da, wo's ging, ist man vorgerückt und ansonsten hat man eben, ja, äh im im Hinterland auch mit viel Arthroriebeschuss äh und so die Russen einfach mürbe äh gemacht,
äh gestört, wo's denn nur irgendein ging.
Genau, also das ist ja eh so ein Bild, was ich gerade äh stark abzeichnet. Da kommen wir dann auch gleich noch mal zu, wenn wir über äh Rakifans und ähm Donezk reden, aber
nicht die die Russen sind immer so in diesem klassischen Attacke äh Modus, wir feuern da jetzt so lange Leute drauf, bis wir hier irgendwie durchbrechen
Ukrainer machen das einfach sehr viel geschmeidiger, weil sie eben auch einen sehr viel
Verletzteres und bessere organisiertes äh Angriffssystem haben. Die setzen digitale Systeme ein, die haben alle irgendwie Tablets. Da stehen dann
Also wenn irgendeine Truppe ein Mienenfeld findet, dann wird das eingetragen, dann sehen das sofort alle anderen. Also die sind einfach über ihre kollektiven Movements ähm informiert, die können das abrufen.
Das mag vielleicht nicht immer überall funktionieren, aber im Prinzip existiert diese Technologie und kommt dort auch zum
zum Einsatz. Also die haben einfach sehr gute Communications, teilen ihre Informationen in Echtzeit und können damit eben sehr viel klüger vorgehen. Und tasten halt immer wieder die russischen Positionen ab
eben diese Information überhaupt nicht zu haben scheinen. Insbesondere
durch diese mobilisierten, die einfach überhaupt keinerlei Ausbildung haben und auch irgendwie komplett ohne irgendwelche Ausrüstung und Funkgeräte äh da einfach in die Gräben geschmissen werden.
Die wissen dann teilweise einfach überhaupt nicht ähm wo sind wir
Wer greift uns an, ja? Was können wir da tun? In welche Richtung sollen wir irgendwie äh schlagen? Wo sind die anderen von uns, ja? Kommen die gerade? Ist diese Stellung dahinten unsere? Also es gibt auch sehr viel Berichte über so Friendly Fire, dass die für so Verluste der Russen
teilweise einfach auch einfach durch eigene Kräfte
ausgelöst wurden, weil sie sich einfach gegenseitig beschossen haben, weil sie einfach nicht wussten, dass auf der anderen Seite äh ihre eigene Armee ist. Ist ja ein generelles Problem in in Kriegen und das betrifft eben jetzt
diese äh Frontlines der Russen mit den schlecht ausgebildeten Soldaten nochmal besonders.
Ja, also es gab, gab Zahlen bis Mönchen gegen den bis zu 60 Prozent der Verluste durch Franky Fire.
Habe ich auch gehört. Also es ist natürlich schwer sowas zu quantifizieren oder diesen Zahlen jetzt zu glauben. Weil ich denke, man kann schon sagen, dass das ein signifikantes Problem ist für die Russen
Nicht das Einzige, was sie haben, aber noch mal eins, was dazu kommt und das vermutlich Friendly Fire bei Ukrainern eher die Ausnahme sein dürfte.
So gut wie sie da eben äh vernetzt sind, ne.
Ja gut, kommt immer vor äh so und äh auch wir jetzt im Golf Golfkrieg gab's auch mehr Tote.
Auf äh Koalitions äh Seite, irgendwie hundertfünfzig ungefähr durch Friendly Feier und äh nur zehn oder 20.
Durch Feindeinwirkung, ja.
Aber gut, auf der anderen Seite hat man äh irgendwie ungefähr hunderttausend gegnerische Truppen äh getötet wahrscheinlich, insofern war das jetzt immer noch ähm ganz gutes Verhältnis.
Trotzdem war der Rückzug äh
schon ein geplanter Rückzug, das sieht man auch da dran, dass dann binnen eines Tages mehrere Brücken gesprengt wurden und zwar jetzt nicht nur die übern, sondern eben äh alle möglichen Brücken, also man wollte generell
einerseits natürlich den Vorstoß, der hm ukrainischen Truppen verlangsamen, aber wahrscheinlich auch einfach mal einfach nur wieder Infrastruktur zerstören, um die Sache teuer zu machen. Auch in der Stadt Ressourcen ist die komplette Strommobilfunk und ich glaube auch Wasserinfrastruktur komplett zerstört worden.
Alles.
Das heißt, sie haben da jetzt erstmal einen Scheiß so ein bisschen, also da funktioniert erstmal sehr viel nicht,
trotz alledem waren da die ähm,
ja der Jubel natürlich groß, als die ukrainischen Soldaten dort in die Stadt gekommen sind.
Hat sich ja nicht lange Zeit gelassen und war nach drei Tagen schon vor Ort, was ich.
Mal wieder sehr tough finde, so weil er war im Prinzip so in Reichweite russischer Artillerie zu dem Zeitpunkt, weil
War ja dann auch auf der anderen Seite des Flusses. Also das äh zeigt schon immer wieder, welchen Mut er hat auf der einen Seite, aber auch welches Vertrauen er in die eigene Armee äh zu haben scheint
klares Signal. Ähm da kann sich Putin mehrere Scheibchen von abschneiden, aber vielleicht sollte er das besser nicht.
Was man woran man vielleicht auch noch erinnern kann, ist, dass äh ja auch die Stadt war, wo es größere Proteste gegen die Russen äh gab in den ersten Wochen, die dann
unterdrück.
Äh wurden, also Demonstrationen gegen gegen die russische Besetzung äh gegen die dann mit Tränengas und dann Verhaftungen äh vorgegangen
wurde, da äh ja.
Und äh ganz viele Leute haben dann ihre ukrainischen Flaggen irgendwo im Garten äh in einer Plastiktüte vergraben und jetzt wieder ausgebuddelt und
dann ähm wie die Wiener hissen zu können. Also da scheint doch ähm,
ja äh eine Menge Leute gegeben äh zu haben oder auch noch zu geben, die.
Mit dem russischen Einmarsch überhaupt nicht einverstanden waren und wahrscheinlich sind dann auch viele, die vielleicht erstmal ja indifferent waren, nachdem sie erlebt haben, wie die Russen sich da aufgeführt haben, haben wahrscheinlich auch ihre Meinung geändert.
Den Eindruck habe ich auch
gewonnen. Ja, vielleicht noch mal kurz zu den Brücken. Also wir haben diese vielen kleinen Brücken im Land gesprengt, aber sie haben natürlich dann auch nochmal die beiden großen Brücken ähm,
die halt jetzt vorher schon von der Ukraine eigentlich die ganze Zeit angegriffen wurde, aber nicht so komplett
zerstört wurden, sondern eben nur so nicht mehr befahrbar gemacht wurden
Also die Antonowski Brücke, die große Brücke bei der Stadt Ressorten. Da sind gleich mehrere Segmente äh zusammengestürzt. Es gab ein bisschen unterschiedliche Berichte darüber, was jetzt diese
Sprengung wirklich ausgelöst hat. Also es ist offensichtlich, dass es so,
so wie so mächtig wie die ähm Explosion war, dass das schon direkt an der Brücke installierte.
Sprengsitze der Russen gewesen sein müssen. Ja, sonst wäre so so ein Einsturz gar nicht äh denkbar. Das geht mit Raketenbeschuss nicht, sonst hätte das ja schon längst stattgefunden.
Ähm aber es gab zumindest so Berichte, dass während des Abzuges der Russen über diese Brücke.
Wo halt viele Truppen rübergelaufen sind. Äh es nochmal massiven Artilleriebeschuss gab durch die Ukraine.
Dabei ähm ein Lastwagen mit Munition getroffen wurde, der dann vielleicht diese Springsätze.
Ja
Alles so ein bisschen Spekulation. Letzten Endes ist das alles so im Dunkeln.
Passiert. Da gibt's zwar Bilder von der Explosion, aber daraus lässt sich eigentlich relativ wenig ableiten, ist auch am Ende völlig egal. Die Situation ist auf jeden Fall so, dass im Nordteil der Antonowski-Brücke hin.
Glaube fünf oder sechs Segmente kaputt sind und wohl auch ein paar Stützen, also das wird dauern bis das äh wieder repariert werden kann.
Und ähm im Osten die zweite große Brücke bei dem Staudamm, beim Nova Kakovka Damm. Da äh verläuft ja der.
Also der eigentliche Staudamm.
Gibt's im vorderen Bereich so ein Schleusen-Ding mit einer Brücke. Das ist das, was die Ukraine die ganze Zeit beschossen hat und wo dann die Russen sich damit geholfen haben, dass sie diesen ganzen Schleusenbereich einfach zugeschüttet haben.
Verläuft aber weiter im Verlauf des Gangs eine eine weitere Brücke und die haben sie dann halt im Nordteil haben sie nochmal drei Segmente gekillt, sowohl den Straßen als auch den.
Eisenbahnteil, sodass auch da ein übersteigendes erstmal nicht so schnell möglich ist, aber ich glaube, das wird sich
für die Ukrainer schneller lösen lassen das Problem, weil das nicht so riesigen Spannweiten sind an der Stelle, sondern das äh dürfte sich mit irgendwie vorgefertigten Brückenteilen ähm wahrscheinlich bald machen lassen.
Ja in ich meine interessant ist auch an.
Der Sache, dass die Russen sich jetzt nicht zutrauen von ihrer Seite aus.
Diese zwei Brücken militärisch zu sichern, ja,
Also quasi sagen, na ja, äh den Ukrainern jetzt eine Falle zu stellen oder die Ukrainer da einfach äh rüberzulassen, um äh ihn dann Verluste durch
äh zuzufügen, müssten wir ja denken, na ja gut, jetzt wo sie sich zurückgezogen haben äh.
Könnten Sie ja eigentlich dort Truppen konzentrieren und äh sagen umgekehrt
die ja die Brücken einfach stehen lassen, aber offensichtlich haben sie Angst vor den Ukrainern, dass sie über die Brücke rüberkommen und äh sie dem nicht standhalten.
Mhm so ich meine anders kann man das jetzt nicht interpretieren, ja, dass sie da alles alles gesprengt haben. Also dass sie offensichtlich nicht damit rechnen
irgendwie jemals in absehbarer Zeit äh wieder auf die andere Seite zu kommen, dass sie im Grunde genommen erst mal kapituliert haben.
An der Stelle.
Das stimmt, das ist ähm das ist offensichtlich. Es gab ja dann noch Gerüchte, dass äh die Russen vielleicht den Damm springen wollen. Die Gerüchte stammen vor allem daher, vor allem, dass die Russen genau dieselben Gerüchte über die Ukrainer veröffentlicht haben
Was ja meistens immer darauf hinweist, dass sie selber äh so was vorhaben. Das war, fand ich schon die ganze Zeit so eine etwas.
Skurrile Geschichte, weil hm es macht aus der russischen.
Sicht heraus gar nicht so sehr Sinn, diesen Staudamm.
Zu killen, ne. Einerseits ist es halt auch wie eben schon von dir erwähnt.
Diese Perspektive mit, na ja, das ist ja eigentlich alles Russland.
Das ja gerade annektiert ja? Ist ja auch irgendwie ihre Infrastruktur ähm also ist es natürlich nicht, aber so aus aus ihrer.
In der aus deren Sicht.
Aus ihrer komischen Logik heraus äh zerstören sie ja quasi jetzt ihr eigenes Land die ganze Zeit
und während man halt so eine Brücke und so weiter mal eben schnell ersetzt bekommt, so würde dieser Staudamm gesprengt werden und würde tatsächlich das ganze Wasser, was dort aufgestaut ist
äh in die das Schwarze Meer gelassen werden, dann wäre das eine Katastrophe, die also erstmal verheerend wäre und zweitens auch.
In absehbarer Zeit auch nicht wieder rückführbar gewesen wäre. Plus es würde eben auch gefährden,
den Weiterbetrieb des Atomkraftwerks, was halt von diesen aufgestauten Wasservorräten vor allem seine Kühlung bezieht. Dazu kommt noch, dass an dieser Stelle speziell auch ja noch der Kanal abgeht, der die Wasserversorgung für die Krim sicherstellt.
Das heißt auch an der Stelle würden sie sich ins eigene Fleisch schneiden, wenn sie eben davon ausgehen, dass sie die Krim noch halten
hätten sie das jetzt sozusagen gesprengt, dann wäre das im Prinzip ja dann auch sofort das Todesurteil für die Krim gewesen. Und was noch dazukommt, ist.
Diese spezielle militärische Situation, die wir jetzt haben, also wir haben diese.
Bei so einer Berichterstattung immer so eine Sache, ne? Es wird manchmal von linken und rechten Ufern, manchmal von Westufer und Ostufer und manchmal von Nord- und Südufer gesprochen, ne? Und das ist halt lustigerweise.
Alles dort richtig. Ja, also auf der einen Seite teilt ja dieser Kniepro.
Die Ukraine mehr oder weniger von Nord nach Süd, macht eben nur auf den letzten Metern nochmal so einen Schlenker gen Westen, so dass man zwar schon vom Westufer reden kann, aber die Stadt Chrisson,
hat das Ufer quasi nach nach Süden und äh der äh östliche Teil
der östliche, der östliche Landmasse, die durch diesen abgetrennt wird, befindet sich eben dann entsprechend dort im Süden der Stadt, also nach Norden äh ist dann die andere Seite. Also
links und rechts bezieht sich ja immer auf den Flussverlauf, das heißt wenn man jetzt quasi das Wasser verfolgt, dann ist die rechte Seite die Westseite, die linke Seite
ist äh die Ostseite beziehungsweise eben dann auf diesen letzten Metern bei der Stadt ist es eben so eine Nord-Süd-Trennung. Und also dieser.
Westliche oder nördliche Teil, da wo die Stadt ist, liegt sehr viel höher als die andere Seite dort, wo die Russen jetzt sind. Das heißt, die Russen haben jetzt ihre neue Verteidigungsstellung dort aufgezogen, befinden sich aber signifikant niedriger.
Als die Stadt Resshon. Würde jetzt dieser Staudamm brechen, explodiert werden, was auch immer.
Dann würde halt das Wasser riesige Gebiete überfluten, würde auch signifikant bestimmte Teile der Stadt mit ähm.
Mitnehmen, ja.
Aber eben auch sehr große Teile nicht, die einfach sehr hoch liegen, während aber da, wo die Russen stehen, eigentlich alles überschwemmt werden würde. Also das wäre aus der Sicht auch.
Gar keine sinnvolle ähm Aktion. Klar, man könnte sagen, okay, wenn das so alles überschwemmt ist, dann können die uns da irgendwie nicht mehr angreifen.
Aber ich habe so den Eindruck, das war ihnen dann auch zu teuer. Jetzt denke ich, sollten eigentlich.
Die also wenn es wirklich Sprengladungen an diesem Damm gegeben hat, dann bin ich mir relativ sicher, dass jetzt die Special Forces der Ukraine diese schon entfernt und entschärft haben.
Zugang dazu haben sie, ne? Sie stehen halt jetzt quasi auf der anderen Seite, aber es gibt jetzt auch Berichte und jetzt kommen wir so ein bisschen in die aktuelle Gerüchteküche, die schon seit Tagen äh ein bisschen hin und her geht. Also was.
Verhältnismäßig gesichert zu sein scheint es, die Russen sind jetzt nicht direkt am anderen Ufer. Genau aus diesen von mir eben genannten Gründen. Sie liegen da so niedrig.
Für die Artillerie aus der Stadt von oben einfach ein gefundenes Fressen sind. Die übersehen da sozusagen alles und wenn du da so einen Höhenunterschied hast, dann ähm dann ist das nicht gut. Dementsprechend.
Heißt es, dass sie sich zehn, 15 bis zu 25 Kilometer ins Land zurückgezogen haben.
Und das wären wirklich gute Nachrichten für die Stadt Resson, denn das würde bedeuten, dass die Stadt,
aus dem Range des Artilleriefeuers der Russen raus ist und bisher
gab es auch noch keine Berichte von äh unmittelbarem Artilleriebeschluss der Stadt.
Man natürlich jetzt vermuten, dass sie sagen, so oh, was, wir kriegen die Stadt nicht mehr, dann machen wir die halt jetzt kaputt, wie wir das überall auch gemacht haben. Wir haben hier ganz viel Artillerie rumstehen, können einfach draufhalten.
Aber es gilt wahrscheinlich auch nach wie vor, dass sie eben.
Probleme haben mit der Logistik, mit dem Nachschub, dass sie jetzt unter Umständen auch ihre Artilleriemunition zusammen äh halten müssen, um dann eben wirkliche Vorstöße äh etwas entgegensetzen zu können
Und ja, sie waren ohnehin so benachteiligt, dass sie sich dann doch auf andere Bereiche zurückgezogen haben.
Sie haben vor allen Dingen haben sie auch so ein grundsätzliches Problem.
Was im Wesentlichen durch Haimas und andere Präzisionsartillerie verursacht.
Wurde, nämlich ähm jedes Mal, wenn jetzt die Russen irgendwo Truppen konzentrieren.
Also und sei es äh sag mal fünf Fahrzeuge oder so auf einem Haufen packen, dann äh wird das halt sofort zum Prioritätsziel für ukrainische Präzisions
Angriffe oder auch für äh nicht präzisionsarthologie.
Und ähm deswegen damit das nicht der Fall sind, haben die Russen sich so die Taktik,
überlegt oder überlegen müssen, dass sie zum einen die größeren Lager sehr weit hinter der Front.
Haben und dann sowohl die Truppen als auch die Lager halt.
Fein aufteilen in viele kleine Grüppchen und kleine Lager damit, die,
besser tarnen können, weil du hast ja dann auch bei einem großen Lager äh hast du halt ständig auch Verkehr äh dass du das nicht so leicht geheimhalten kannst. Nur durch diese,
sage mal Zersplitterung äh brauchst du natürlich von der Logistik her.
Äh einen viel größeren Aufwand und du hast nicht mehr so viel Überblick, wo eigentlich dein ganzer Kram lagert. Und dann kommt noch dazu, dass die Russen ja mit sogenannter Puschlogistik arbeiten.
Also äh im Gegensatz die NATO da fordern die Truppen dann an, was sie brauchen, während äh bei den Russen
man so ungefähr weiß so wie wie viel braucht so eine Truppe und dann wird halt von oben einfach geliefert und ähm
Das führt dann natürlich viel leichter zu Fehlallokationen.
Heißt, dass wahrscheinlich es irgendwo Truppen gibt, die gar nicht wissen, wohin mit dem ganzen Krempel.
Weil äh ja sie gar nicht jetzt direkt im Kampf stehen oder einen ganz anderen Verbrauch äh
haben äh oder weil man nicht genau weiß, wie viele Truppen eigentlich wo äh sind, weil die Zahlen eben nicht stimmen während es halt bei anderen Truppen allein schon am Trinkwasser
mangelt, äh weil sie nicht mal in der Lage sind, an den nächsten Bach oder die nächste Quelle äh zu gehen, weil sie äh ständig eben dann.
Ukrainische Drohnen oder Artilleriebeschuss äh fürchten und quasi dann auch noch mitten in einem in einem Land, was total nass und feucht ist irgendwie auch noch am Verdursten sind.
Ja also ist alles äh.
Situation, wo nicht klar ist, wie feststeht die Verteidigungslinie der Russen an der Stelle tatsächlich.
Das ist jetzt sicherlich auch Fokus der ukrainischen Armee, das neu herauszufinden und neue Pläne zu machen.
Während sie natürlich jetzt auch erstmal mit der Sicherung und der Instandsetzung der Infrastruktur beschäftigt sind, sie müssen sicherlich auch noch.
Das Cleaning durchführen, also das ist so der Begriff für.
Entschuldigung nicht das also wenn halt 'ne Stadt eingenommen wird dann muss man.
Von Haus zu Haus, von Keller zu Keller schauen, dass ich da nicht irgendwelche Soldaten äh hinter den Linien eingesperrt haben. Es gab da 1tausend Berichte, dass die sich dann einfach.
Ihrer Soldatenkleidung entledigt haben und zivil irgendwo rumhangen, um irgendwie äh davonzukommen oder vielleicht auch.
Linien zu infiltrieren, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das von sehr viel Erfolg gekrönt sein dürfte. Ist auch ein bisschen unklar, wie groß jetzt die Verluste waren. Die Russen haben ja selber gesagt.
Super, kein Problem, kein Mann verloren, keinen Panzer zurückgelassen,
Tatsächlich ist der Verlust an Gerät relativ gering, also es ist nicht so, dass jetzt nicht zurückgelassen wurde, aber es ist jetzt nicht wie in äh Isum, das verwundert so ein bisschen, weil ja durch diese Brücken im Prinzip.
Genau dieser Rückzug von schwerem Gerät eigentlich erschwert worden sein sollte.
Trotzdem habe ich jetzt nicht so viel gesehen, dass da jetzt äh riesige Mengen an Munition oder eben auch an schwerem Gerät.
Die Hände der äh Ukraine gefallen sind, aber es war wohl schon auch etwas. Also ich kenne jetzt bloß die Zahlen nicht, aber es äh war jetzt nicht im,
übermäßig viel, aber es sind dann eben schon viele
Russentod äh im Fluss gefunden worden, die also dann es nicht geschafft haben über diesen Fluss zu kommen et cetera,
die Verluste sind äh an der Stelle ein bisschen unspezifisch. Insgesamt
haben wir allerdings eine enorm hohe Verlustquote der russischen Armee, also
täglich gehen, irgendwie so zwischen also laut den Zahlen der ukrainischen Armee, die die veröffentlichen, ja, also was sie meinen, was was sie.
Meinen gesehen zu haben oder behaupten zu können in der Größenordnung von 500 bis 800 pro Tag.
Enorme Zahlen sind, ne und äh man kann auch davon ausgehen, dass die Verluste bei der Ukraine jetzt auch nicht null sind, sondern dass äh,
vielleicht so ein Verhältnis von 1 zu 8, 1 zu zehn derzeit äh existiert. Also der Verlust der Ukraine sind sicherlich niedriger. Das hat.
Viel mit ähm ihrer besseren Ausrüstung zu tun, ja. Die haben einen besseren mhm,
Schutz gegen äh Munition, also solche Schutzwesten, Helme sind besser, generell ist die Ausrüstung besser, die medizinische Versorgung ist besser. Die Soldaten sind auch nicht so ausgepowert, die werden regelmäßig durchrotiert, mentale Belastung wird.
Von daher auch ähm besser kontrolliert. Ist natürlich trotzdem hoch. All diese ganzen Faktoren, das gilt halt für die Russen irgendwie kaum. Dazu kommt dann eben noch die Situation mit der schlechten Ausbildung äh und der schlechten Ausrüstung und jetzt gerade im Winter
durfte das nochmal ein Problem werden. Da kommen wir aber auch gleich nochmal separat dazu. Vielleicht erstmal die Situation in nochmal.
Abschließend, also die rechte Nibro-Seite,
komplett unter ukrainischer Kontrolle. Das kann man mit Sicherheit sagen und und ob die andere Seite komplett unter russischer Kontrolle ist, da gab's einiges.
Hin und her, also es ging dann relativ schnell, dass so Berichte kamen so, ja, die ukrainische Special Force sind jetzt mit,
auf die andere Seite gegangen des Flusses an verschiedenen Stellen angelandet und fahren da irgendwelche Attacken und viel wurde auch über diese Landzunge hm spekuliert.
Das ist ja so ein eher so ein Naturschutzgebiet da am Süden äh so sandige würde man sagen fast schon so.
Syltartige äh Strukturen, ja, so ein bisschen so ein Nordseeinselstyle mit viel äh Sand und Büschen, alles sehr flach im Wasser. Ähm wo.
Ja, man sich nicht groß verstecken kann, aber wo man auch mit schwerem Gerät nicht unbedingt.
Problemlos durchfahren kann, weil's einfach keine befestigten Straßen gibt, sondern eben alles sehr sandig ist und wurde eben gemunkelt, dass dort äh die Ukraine rübergesetzt hat mit kleinen Schiffchen, um dort irgendwelche Spätposten zu
bestreiten. Das kann alles sein, aber das ist alles überhaupt nicht bestätigt und ähm
Gab dann auch Berichte, dass schon irgendwie erste Städte wieder eingenommen wurden. Das ist aber Quatsch, sondern das hat wohl eher was damit zu tun, dass die Russen sich eben einfach von alleine
paar Kilometer zurückgezogen haben und die kleinen Dörfchen, die also jetzt wirklich an der Nordseite äh sind, dass die halt einfach derzeit grayzon sind, also so ein
unumkämpfter Bereich oder vielleicht um faktisch umgekämpfter Bereich, aber eben derzeit.
Niemand und ähm niemand hat da die Kontrolle dadrüber und äh macht da irgendwas, ne.
Ja, also diese diese Ecke äh da ist im Prinzip auch sozusagen der Flusskilometer null des Drah. Äh da fängt äh der Fluss äh eigentlich an und ähm,
Ja, es ist halt schon auch ziemlich weit.
Von jetzt generell Nachschub, egal auf welche aus welchem Wege
er kommt und es gab auch schon recht früh Meldungen auch noch also bevor
Jetzt das die Nordseite von der Ukraine ganz befreit war, dass äh die Russen
auch auf der Südseite, also auf ihrer eigenen Seite äh Evakuierungen vornehmen,
So also dass sie sich nicht nur auf die Nordseite beschränkt haben, sondern eben auch äh dort ja Truppen aus der,
Südwest äh aus dem Südwestzipfel äh zurückgezogen haben,
weil eben dort ja die die Versorgungswege einfach lang.
Das können Sie einfach genauso wenig halten wie die ähm Versorgung eben im nördlichen Teil, den Sie jetzt verlassen mussten und das ist so ein bisschen das Dilemma der Russen, dieser ganze Oblaste Ressourcen ist nochmal.
Viel extremer als schon der jetzt gerade von ihnen verlassene Teil einfach weites Land. Ja also da ist wenn man sich das mal anschaut das ist halt einfach eine einzige
Agrarwüste immer mal wieder ein kleines Dörfchen
Filder, Filter, Filter, Filter, Filter, Filter, Filter, soweit das Auge reicht. Also ein riesiges Gebiet, in dem einfach sehr wenig
wirkliche städtische Infrastruktur ist. Es gibt einfach nur so ein paar kleinere
Örtchen, die so am Meer 'ne gewisse Dichte aufweisen, wie dem dieses Gadows, aber das ist dann eben so weit weg vom Schuss und so wenig mit allem anderen verbunden, dass es sich eben auch fast nicht lohnt, dort große Truppenkonzentrationen
zu halten, zumal ein Vorstoß der Ukraine einfach wahrscheinlich an diesen Städten mehr oder weniger dran vorbeigehen würde und diese Versorgungslinien durchschneidet und dann stehen sie halt genauso doof,
und es macht derzeit so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob sie ihr Kommand und Kontrollzentrum und irgendwie ihre gesamten und Truppenkonzentrationen
tatsächlich mehr auf den.
Ja auf die Grenze zu Krim konzentrieren und von dort äh auch eben die Kämpfe in Saporissia.
Also weiter hoch, den Fluss, ähm da wo das Kraftwerk ist, dort äh darauf zu
konzentrieren, weil das sieht so ein bisschen aus, als könnte das eben so das nächste Theater sein, in dem die Kriegs äh Wallungen weitergehen.
Ja, ja. An sich dachte ich mir noch, hm okay.
Warum bringen die Russen jetzt nicht vielleicht.
Die Ukrainer in dieselbe, unangenehme Situation, in der sie vorher äh waren, also quasi erlauben den Ukrainern jetzt einen Brückenkopf auf dem anderen Ufer aufzumachen.
Und drehen quasi den Spieß um. Aber äh das scheint halt weder die geografische Lage zu äh ermöglichen wegen dem Höhenunterschied und gegen die du gerade ausgeführt hast äh.
Ganz unterschiedlichen Besiedlungsgrad plus, dass es den Russen einfach an den entsprechenden Waffensystemen auch mangelt, um eben genau das äh.
Dann symmetrisch äh umzukehren, sodass.
Mein Eindruck ist, dass Sie sich innerlich auch schon von mehr äh Gebiet verabschiedet äh haben, äh was Sie wahrscheinlich erst mal nicht in der Lage sein werden, zu verteidigen.
Ja, das kann gut sein. Summa summarum.
Muss man jetzt festhalten durch diesen erfolgreichen Kriegszug, diese erfolgreiche Rückeroberung von statt und der entsprechend drumrum liegenden Gebiete nördlich des Flusses oder.
Des Flusses. Ähm hat jetzt Ukraine die Hälfte der Gebiete wieder befreit bekommen,
die die Russen insgesamt in diesem ganzen Krieg besitzt haben, also einschließlich der Vorstöße in Kiew, Rakiew, also all das, wo.
Ukrainisches Territorium mal unter russischer Kontrolle war,
Die Hälfte davon ist jetzt wieder äh zurückerobert worden und das ist schon mal ein ziemlich großer Erfolg.
Ich glaube, die Ukrainer werden jetzt auch nicht äh groß, einen Pausenmodus machen.
Einfach weiterkämpfen und versuchen weiterhin die großen unter Druck zu erhalten, denn die sind sagen wir mal also eine Pause können da sicherlich alle mal gebrauchen.
Aber eine Pause könnten die Russen natürlich überproportional mehr nutzen.
Als die Ukrainer, weil sie dann eben sich wieder verstärken können. Aber derzeit sind sie einfach die ganze Zeit auf dem linken Fuß und äh Ukraine versucht ihn halt ähm.
Möglichst viele Schläge zuzusetzen, so es eben in ihren eigenen Kräften steht.
So, das gibt uns die äh Gelegenheit und den Auftrag auch noch
Zweites Kriegsgebiet mal anzuschauen, wo es ja auch schon seit einiger Zeit äh vorangeht. Das ist eben
ich würde es jetzt mal die Luhansk-Offensive nennen äh äh Offensive. Es ist zwar jetzt noch nicht der letzte Quadratzentimeter des Oblast Rakif befreit, aber eben ja so gut wie.
Dann nur noch so einen nördlichen Streifen, der jetzt äh technisch fehlt.
Aber es geht natürlich jetzt um die Rückeroberung von äh Luhansk, weil das ist jetzt sozusagen genau das Gebiet, wo die aktuelle Frontlinie im Nordosten steht.
Und ähm ja, das hängt ja alles zusammen mit dieser.
Super erfolgreichen schnellen Rückeroberung größerer Gebiete, über die wir hier schon viel gesprochen haben, Rakif.
Die Ukraine hat dort halt eine Lücke gesehen, eine äh hat schwache Stellung gesehen, hat dann in Windeseile das ganze Gebiet bis äh kopiansk.
In Beschlag genommen, das was also
diesen Ost Kiel äh Fluss getrennt wird, der dort von Nord nach Süden läuft und in dem Zuge dann halt erst die wichtige Stadt Isum wieder zurückerobert, die halt so ein ganz wichtiger Brückenkopf war für
die Russen im Kampf um Donetsk und dann später eben auch noch die genauso wichtige Stadt Lüman, die eine ähnliche Funktion hatte
sie dann eben von diesem weiter nach ähm Osten vorgestoßen sind. Und dort gab's dann auch
für eins, zwei Wochen weitere äh Erfolge, sodass diese ganze Frontlinie
ähm an so eine wichtige Straße herangeführt werden konnte, die P 6undsechzig, die halt dann diesen Ort äh Kopiansk mit den
industriellen Gebieten, um et cetera Luci Chansk verbindet. Das ist eine ganz wichtige Linie für die Russen um den Norden von Luhansk äh zu halten. Dort gibt's
auch noch mal so geografisch ein ähm
Eine Trennung einerseits gibt's dann erstmal äh Waldgebiete. Dahinter geht's dann aber auch wieder ähm nach unten, also für die Russen vielleicht gar nicht so gut und die wichtige Stadt ist dort eben. Die versuchen die Russen jetzt gerade zu verteidigen.
Das gelingt ihnen so halbwegs, aber äh die Ukraine macht also hier Fortschritte.
Und wenn jetzt Truppen, die aus frei geworden sind und da.
War ja von 60.000 die Rede. So viel werden sie jetzt nicht brauchen, um diese Stellung dort zu halten.
Können sie also keine Ahnung wie viele, aber viele neu äh verteilen und mich würde das nicht überraschen, wenn sie sowohl jetzt diese Front äh.
Luhansk Front damit äh verstärken als auch zwei, drei andere Punkte, auf die ich gleich noch eingehen werde. So und damit könnten dann weitere Vorstöße möglich sein. Sind da schon relativ weit.
Ist ein bisschen schwierig zu sagen, wann sich hier etwas nennenswert äh verbessert, aber auch hier geht die Ukraine relativ klug vor. Also sie tasten immer wieder ab, wo es Widerstand, wo kann man durchschießen
Russen machen Gegenoffensiven, die werden in der Regel immer zurückgeschlagen äh,
eine recht blutige Veranstaltung, wenn man in Zahlen dort glauben darf.
Dort immer wieder genannt werden es macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck als ob das hier auch wieder so.
Nutzungs äh Krieg ist, es wird sich zeigen, inwiefern die Wälder dort für die Russen noch ein sinnvolles äh Versteck sind mit ihrer Artillerie, wenn jetzt der Herbst voll einsetzt, ja also.
Klar, ne, also wenn's nicht jetzt grade Nadelwald ist, dann wird einfach nicht mehr sehr viel,
Blätter äh Dickicht am Start sein und natürlich auch die äh allgemeine Kältesituation und die schlechte Ausrüstung, das könnte alles eine Rolle spielen. Gilt natürlich umgekehrt genauso auch für die Ukraine
aber es gibt schon so verschiedenste Anzeichen, dass äh
ja also in an irgendeiner Stelle dieser Front äh es demnächst knacken könnte.
Was was immer auch noch eine Rolle spielt, wenn man sich das mal so im Profil anguckt oder im im Satellitenbild, stellt man fest, dass.
Die Gegend, wo die Front sich jetzt hin verlagert hat, äh etwas.
Ungünstig ist für einen schnellen, mobilen Kampf, die es glaube ich relativ hügelig, relativ
bewaldet und mit ja eher so
vielen kleineren auch Flussläufen durchschnitten, die dann jeweils immer Taylor äh bilden und zwar hauptsächlich so in Nord-Süd-Richtung.
Was äh halt bedeutet, ja, dass dass eben,
diese Gegend gerade den den Verteidiger äh so ein bisschen bevorteilt und das eben schwieriger macht jetzt dort so einen schnellen äh Durchmarsch zu erzielen, aber,
ähm im Winter frieren eben viele dieser Flüsse auch zu.
So, das heißt, äh der Winter verändert nicht nur, dass es weniger Laub gibt, sondern es werden dann plötzlich auch irgendwann, wenn halt Frost einsetzt da oben
werden plötzlich ganz andere äh Stellen eben auch wieder passierbar, nämlich man kann dann teilweise sogar mit Fahrzeugen einfach über die Flüsse rüberfahren, die stellen dann nicht mehr so ein so ein Hindernis
da und das kann dann auch nochmal eine neue Dynamik in das Ganze bringen da oben
und äh wenn halt jetzt ein Vorstoß dann eben tatsächlich in Ostrichtung äh erfolgt.
Dann äh die die ganzen Versorgungswege laufen eben auch vom äh äh Norden nach nach Süden
und äh wie gesagt in in
in Ostrichtung zu gehen, da sind dann eben die meisten Hindernisse, aber wenn man das einmal durchbrochen hat, dann kann man eben relativ schnell dann äh äh wiederum nach nach Süden äh äh durch.
Durchmarschieren beziehungsweise äh haben dann die Truppen äh im im Süden äh den kann man dann die Versorgungswege abschneiden. Also in der Tat da ist jetzt einiges drin
äh für den Winter habe ich das Gefühl, dass sich da irgendwann äh wieder eine neue Dynamik einstellen könnte in der Luhansk-Region.
Das zeigt ja auch, also es gibt ja noch so eine etwas obskure Bewegung in diesem Bereich und zwar die sogenannte Wagnerlinie.
Danach benannt, nach diesem
Wagner, Privatmilitär, Truppen, die das wohl in irgendeiner Form koordinieren und das ist wirklich eine etwas verstörende Nummer. Also was wird dort getan? Es sind größere Mengen an so Betonpyramiden ähm hergestellt worden und werden dort mit Trucks
großräumig auf so einer Verteidigungslinie verteilt. Wenn man sich aber diese Linie anschaut, wo die liegt.
Dann macht es mehr so den Eindruck, als ob das so der Kernbereich des 20014eroberten Gebietes um Luhansk Stadt äh et cetera ist.
Also überhaupt nicht da, wo jetzt grade die Frontlinie ist, sondern deutlich weiter zurückgesetzt und eben auch nicht vollständig der ganze Bereich von Luhansk, der ganze Norden, von Luhansk äh nicht, sondern nur eben die Stadt ähm et cetera.
Einerseits, andererseits gibt es auch für Verteidigungslinien in Russland, die dort gebaut werden, was völlig verstörend ist, also um,
ähm die Gegend da äh Belgo Rott, also jenseits der ukrainischen russischen Grenze werden solche Verteidigungslinien auch aufgezogen
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich davon halten soll, diese Verteidigungslinien, das sind halt so im Prinzip immer so
zwei Linien, wo dann so im regelmäßigen Abstand diese Beton Pyramiden abgesetzt werden, die vielleicht, was weiß ich, wie hoch sind die, eins fünfzig oder so, keine Ahnung, nicht besonders hoch.
Diese Drachenzähne werden die auch genannt, Dragon Ties und wie hießen Deutsch schießen die noch anders? Das gab's auch schon im ersten Weltkrieg
die Dinger, nur die Russen haben glaube ich auch noch eine Billigvariante davon. Eigentlich werden die eigentlich werden die wohl eingegraben normalerweise, damit die da damit man die eben nicht einfach mit einem Radlader wegschieben kann,
aber äh.
Die einfach nur so auf die Erde, ne.
Aber bei den Russen ist es mehr irgendwie Optik. Die kippen die da ab äh und das äh Einzige ja wogegen
die helfen ist, dass ja ähm.
Du da nicht nicht einfach mitm Auto äh.
Lang fahren kannst, sondern halt ja irgendwas brauchst.
Den Eindruck habe ich nicht so richtig, weil für ein Auto sind dann die Abstände dann teilweise auch wiederum zu groß und ich habe auch schon ähm
irgendwo ein Filmchen gesehen, wo ein gepanzertes Fahrzeug über diese Dinger einfach rüber
ockelt. Also das was viel bringt, da habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, aber man man wundert sich ja bei den russischen Verteidigungslinien.
Mittlerweile eigentlich über gar nix mehr so richtig.
Also um vielleicht die Situation jetzt hier äh kurz abzuschließen. Man muss halt noch sagen, also auch hier wie auch an vielen anderen Stellen.
Werden halt immer wieder viele von diesen mobilisierten Truppen eingesetzt. Das ist halt ähm alles nicht so schön.
Berichte verdichten sich immer wieder äh auf dieselben Storys. Diese Leute werden da viel zu schnell hinverlegt. Die sind sozusagen von diesen insgesamt mobilisierten
ist halt einfach so ein gewisser Teil einfach auserwählt worden, um einfach sofort an die Front zu gehen und die setzen sie dann ganz vorne in die allererste Verteidigungslinie, drücken ihn irgendwie ein paar Waffen in die Hand
damit sie ein bisschen paff machen können, aber sind einfach nicht gut ausgerüstet und wie vorhin schon erwähnt
auch nicht besonders äh gut mit Kommunikation äh versorgt und sitzen da teilweise rum, haben nix zu essen, haben nix zu trinken ähm und äh werden die ganze Zeit mit Artillerie Feuer beballert und entsprechend hoch sind die Verluste
aber auch nicht so ohne Weiteres fliehen
Weil eben die Reihen dahinter den Auftrag haben, die dann einfach abzuknallen, wenn sie irgendwie desertieren möchten. Also es ist alles ziemlich böse, was da läuft bei den Russen ähm für die Moral und den Zusammenhalt der Armee
nicht viel getan.
Ähm aber das ist nun mal diese Situation und man geht davon aus, dass also auch in Johannes so die Verluste der Russen äh locker sieben bis zehn Mal so hoch sind wie die der Ukraine.
Ja, dann vielleicht nochmal eine ein Blick auf die Situation in Dunetzk
Da gibt's immer relativ wenig zu berichten, weil eigentlich immer dasselbe passiert. Also wären wir jetzt mit der Luhansk ähm
Front, den nordöstlichen Teil des Frontverlaufs, der sich ja so einmal sichelmäßig jetzt so um diese Ukraine herumlegt
besprochen haben, ist eben Douniz, der daran anschließende im Süden anschließende Teil,
Sprich, das sind so die Kämpfe, sowohl um.
Die Region um die Stadt.
Als auch ein bisschen weiter nördlich, insbesondere der Kampf um die Stadt Bachmuth, die ja jetzt schon lange immer wieder genannt wird. Das ist so ein bisschen der Ausläufer der Kämpfe,
Im Sommer hatten, um nachdem die Russen das eingenommen hatten, sind sie relativ weit vorgedrungen und
dachten alle schon so oho oh Gott oh Gott was passiert jetzt? Das war dann eigentlich genau der Moment wodurch das Eintreffen der modernen europäischen und amerikanischen Artillerie
die Ukraine das Blatt,
drehen konnte. Also bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt sah es wirklich brenzlig aus und durch diese Waffen konnten dann eben die äh Russen so ein bisschen ähm auf ihrem Platz gehalten werden
trotzdem und das ist halt dann auch wieder so eine Story mit diesen Wagner, Privatmilitärgruppen von diesem, wie heißt der Vogel nochmal, Prilo, ich.
Genau, ne, also so ein Milliardär, dem das irgendwie alles gehört und der halt jetzt unbedingt dort äh Fortschritte machen will, weil es im Prinzip überhaupt der einzige Bereich ist, wo Russland überhaupt irgendwelche Fortschritte macht.
Fortschritte bewegen sich eher so in muss man eher in Metern bemessen als in Kilometern. Es gab jetzt in den letzten zwei Wochen dort
mal wieder größere Vorstöße. Die meisten werden immer wieder zurückgeschlagen. Jetzt äh haben sich die Kampfhandlungen wieder etwas näher an die Stadt Bach Mut.
Aber es geht da halt einfach immer hin und her und die Verluste äh sind auf beiden Seiten groß. Das ist so ein ganz ekliger Teil. Es ist vor allem auch so ein bisschen absurd, selbst wenn die Russen Bachmut einnehmen würden
ist damit nicht viel gewonnen, weil dahinter liegen dann wiederum weitere Verteidigungslinien ähm der äh Ukraine insbesondere
sozusagen alles in Richtung und ist so quasi die Burg, das ist schon immer so das Zentrum des ukrainischen Widerstands gewesen, seit zwanzig ähvierzehn
Vorstellung, dass die Russen hier in irgendeiner Form militärisch nennenswert noch einen Blumentopf gewinnen können, die die.
Einfach ähm kann man einfach derzeit ausschließen. Dafür haben sie einfach die Power nicht. Nichtsdestotrotz wird dann einfach Menschenmaterial verheizt ohne Ende und auch Artillerie.
Alles, was irgendwie geht.
Man versteht das nicht und auch in Donez bei der Stadt Donezk gibt's verstärkte ähm Offensiven und ähm ein paar.
Orte, die äh die Ukraine jetzt eigentlich seit einem halben Jahr hält ähm konnten dann zurück.
Äh was heißt zurück? Überhaupt erstmal erobert werden von den äh Russen,
Aber das handelt sich auch hier äh.
Einfach um Fortschritte im im 100 Meter Bereich völlig absurd.
Um den Topf dann gleich noch zuzumachen, wo es gerade auch noch wild abgeht, was ja auch noch so ein Tor ist, das ist halt auch wieder so ein äh Ort des permanenten Kopfschüttelns, Pawlifka,
da. Das sind so diese beiden.
Städte. Das ist von daher ganz interessant, das ist ja dann sozusagen schon so in der Mitte dieser ganzen Frontlinie und das wäre so ein bisschen das Tor nach Marienpol, nach dieser.
Extrem zerstörten
am Asowschen Meer und ähm hier wollen die Russen auf jeden Fall verhindern, dass die Ukrainer vorstoßen und versuchen das eben mit einer Gegenoffensive. Das ist jetzt schon irgendwie die zehnte oder zwölfte Gegenoffensive in den letzten paar Wochen.
Die permanent immer wieder zurückgeschlagen äh wird. Auch hier sind die Verluste groß. Auch hier kämpfen sie quasi ab Hill, also die
da als höher als die Stadt und die Russen versuchen, Pavlifka zu erobern, aber es gelingt ihnen irgendwie nur
sehr begrenzt dort Fortschritte zu machen und wenn die ganze Zeit wieder zurückgeschlagen das wirkt alles etwas äh verzweifelt und das sind alles so Teile wo man sich denken kann, dass wenn die Ukraine
hier ihre zweite Welle startet und äh quasi die Leute, die jetzt in frei geworden sind zum Einsatz bringt und vielleicht eben auch nochmal ein neues Waffenmaterial, dass sich hier das Blatt schnell wenden könnte, denn
dieser gesamten Linie gilt natürlich das Ding, sollte es der Ukraine jetzt gelingen, in irgendeiner Form auf dieser breiten Frontlinie.
Bist du Netz dort vorzustoßen und so einen Spalt äh.
Die russische ähm Besetzungslinie reinzustoßen und vielleicht sogar bis ähm zur ähm,
also mehr vorzudringen, dann werden auch noch die letzten Versorgungslinien aus Russland für den Resonnenbereich komplett abgetrennt. Und da haben natürlich die.
Russen riesen Sackgang.
Trotz alledem sehen wir eben das, was wir schon seit Monaten sehen mit der Halmasraketen und Raketen und anderen Systemen werden einfach permanent.
Kommandostrukturen zerstört, ähm größere Soldatenansammlungen angegriffen,
und ähm vor allem eben so Munitionslager und andere Logistikzentren zerstört und das ist halt einfach so desbals Haus, so das
ne? Hier hauen wir euch weg. Da hauen wir euch weg. Unsere Aufklärung ist besser, unsere Artillerie ist besser. Wir äh machen euch einfach mürbe und der Winter kommt und ihr habt irgendwie
Ja, eigentlich keine Chance. Das ist so ein bisschen das.
Und das ist dann auch glaube ich so ein bisschen die Zusammenfassung, wie es militärisch jetzt äh insgesamt so aussieht.
Ja ähm also.
Ist es natürlich jetzt strategisch
sagen, es ist genau der Ort, wo jetzt alle davon ausgehen, äh dass äh es darum
äh gehen wird, weshalb so richtig sagt, dass die Russen dort auch versuchen jetzt ihre Truppen zu konzentrieren und das halt möglichst zu verhindern und äh ja ist die Frage
wird halt deswegen dann wieder äh
irgendwas eher Überraschendes passieren an an anderer Stelle äh so und äh sozusagen noch noch mal so eine so eine Nummer wie
äh so so ein so ein.
So ein Doppelpack, äh wo man dann erstmal an anderer Stelle angreift, weil klar ist, dass äh die andere Seite irgendeinen Punkt
unbedingt haltend äh äh will und äh ja also wird wird bin gespannt äh wo das passieren wird. Ich
bin aber im Moment auch fast äh,
ja an dem an dem Punkt, dass äh ja wahrscheinlich die Russen ähm nur nur wenige Fronten äh äh werden werden wirklich dauerhaft
halten können. Aber da kommen wir gleich noch zu, um das Thema auch noch mal äh zu beenden, noch zwei Sachen zum zum Wagner Thema.
Das eine ist, dass nach russischem Gesetz eigentlich solche äh Private Military Companies verboten sind. Ja
Aber hat jetzt ja in äh Sankt Petersburg so ein Startup-Zentrum
aufgebaut wurde dann irgendwie auch Leute rekrutiert und neue Technologien entwickelt werden,
äh sollen und ähm hat sich da mit den
lokalen Behörden gerade angelegt und liefert sich dort einen Machtkampf wegen diesem Zentrum, wo die ihm wohl bisher aber die Genehmigung dafür verweigern, also dass sozusagen eine.
Sache, die sich dort gerade abspielt und die zweite Sache ist, dass äh Wagner ja auch die Truppe ist, die eben vor allem in Gefängnissen Strafgefangene,
rekrutiert hat und unter diesen Strafgefangenen
gibt's dann eben noch mal eine spezielle Gruppe mit besonders niedrigem Status. An sowas wie aussätzigen Bataillone. Das sind nämlich Leute, die irgendwie,
an Krankheiten leiden, also typischerweise Aids HIV.
Äh oder Tuberkulose oder andere äh.
Dinge
und die werden auch genommen und kommen dann eben wohl in spezielle Bataillone, die dann ganz vorne an der Front sind und die dann auch spezielle Aufnäher tragen müssen und die dann halt vor allem von den Barrikadetruppen
zurückgehalten werden und quasi sagen das das sind dann die,
die Untersten der Untersten, wenn man, wenn man so will, was so Truppen angeht, auch sehr unappetitlich, das.
Sind auch die Berichte, dass diejenigen, die sich jetzt wirklich dem Kampf äh verweigern, dann wiederum in
speziellen Gefängnissen im Keller gehalten äh werden äh entsprechend malträtiert, schlecht versorgt werden und gezwungen werden sollen, dort äh an die.
An die Front zu gehen. Also alles, was man da hört, ist einfach.
Ein äh einfach schlecht auf allen Ebenen, das ist äh es ist wirklich äh schlimm und spricht vor allem alles nicht dafür, dass.
Dass ich hier in irgendeiner Form nochmal eine Armee herausbilden kann, die wirklich die Werbe hat. Hier diesen Krieg einen neuen Spin zu geben, sondern das riecht einfach alles total nach Untergang.
Tocking about Untergang. Winter is coming.
Ja
Bevor wir ähm zum zum Wetter äh äh kommen ähm in dem also zu oder zum zum Winter kommen, äh würde ich würde ich gerne als erstes nochmal das das Thema
Lügen äh äh ansprechen, äh weil das auch noch mal äh
ganz ganz gut erklärt. Da gab's ein Video von äh Peru eben auch zu, der das mal untersucht hat und ähm
das kann ich kann ich auch nur nur wärmstens empfehlen. Es wird was über eine eine Stunde ungefähr, wo man dann denkt
ähm na ja, Moment mal mit äh äh wie ergiebig soll das das Thema Lügen äh jetzt schon sein? Das klingt so ein bisschen
oberflächlich aber äh tatsächlich äh,
war das super interessant und äh liefert eben auch sehr, sehr viel Erklärungspotential so für Dinge, die bei den Russen jetzt tatsächlich schiefgelaufen äh sind und hm vielleicht.
Äh muss man dazu erstmal wissen, dass die Russen oder das russische Militär.
Ähm eigentlich sehr mathematisch wissenschaft,
vorgeht bei ihren Plänen und
und kämpfen. Wir hatten ja ein paar Jahrzehnte Zeit, das mit dem ganzen Kriegshandwerk.
So äh alles zu durchleuchten und zu durchrechnen und die haben halt
im Prinzip komplexe Algorithmen, wenn man so will, die dann meistens in irgendwelchen Tabellen und Diagrammen zusammengefasst sind, wo dann steht, dass er sich okay für jetzt äh hundert,
äh Meter Frontabschnitt oder für für ein Kilometer Frontabschnitt braucht man jetzt so und so viel Truppen und um jetzt Gebiet von der und der Größe ähm zu beschießen, muss man mit so und so viel
Granaten von dem und dem Kalima äh
jetzt vorgehen und halt all solche Dinge und also haben wir halt sehr, sehr viele Formeln und was weiß ich und wenn ich dann einen Angriff
machen will und.
Setzt sich da die Zahlen auch der gegnerischen Truppen und gegnerischen Bewaffnungen ein und dann fällt halt raus und dann setzt sich halt meine Truppen ein und dann kriege ich so eine Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit wie wahrscheinlich ist es
äh dass ich dann an der Stelle gewinne und äh wie groß sind dann wahrscheinlich meine Verluste so. Also so.
Arbeiten, die eben teilweise, wie gesagt, sehr schematisch, mathematisch und
diese ja diese Logik wurde dann auch nach dem nach Ende des Kalten Krieges, als man da Zugang zu hatte wurde das dann auch mal so von westlichen ja äh Forschern mal durchsucht
äh äh durch durchleuchtet und dann kam man zu dem Ergebnis, ja das
macht eigentlich alles Sinn, was die Russen da, also das Tabellenwerk und äh was sie da so für ihre Art von von Kampf und und
äh äh Taktik äh haben. Das schien alles, wie so schön heißt, Sound äh also äh ja funktioniert grundsätzlich sinnvoll, macht Sinn.
Problem ist nur hm da kommen wir jetzt zu dem Thema Lügen. Mhm.
In der russischen Armee, mein das hat sich,
so eine spezielle, wenn wir Lügenkultur ein äh gestellt. Ähm aus.
Verschiedenen Gründen, aber vor allem eben ja aus, ich sage mal System, also.
Anderen Worten ähm.
Wenn du jetzt einen Bericht schreibst, angefangen,
jetzt in Friedenszeiten wie viel deiner Panzer sind jetzt einsatzbereit.
Ähm dann tendieren in Russland.
Leute einfach ein bisschen äh zu schön
die Zahlen, die gemeldet werden, nach oben oder auch wie viel Truppen hast du jetzt, äh wie viel Leute hast du äh grade, äh die im Einsatz sind, weil dementsprechend laufen natürlich dann Zuteilungen und.
Wenn du jetzt ehrlich berichtest auf 50 Prozent meiner Fahrzeuge sind Schrott
und alle anderen Kommandeure berichten Orebounds sind achtzig, 90 Prozent der der Fahrzeuge einsatzbereit, dann bist du natürlich derjenige, der dann schlecht aussieht so im
im Vergleich. Also äh bist du quasi fast gezwungen ähm.
Auch zu schönen, weil ähm sonst ja äh du nirgendwo hinkommst, dann wirst du eben eher eher bestraft, wenn du einfach schlechte Zahlen äh äh nach oben meldest. So.
Und äh dann im Krieg geht das eben noch noch weiter mit mit diesen.
Meldungen jetzt. Jetzt wurden die Truppen halt in die Ukraine geschickt.
Basis jetzt dieser mhm ja übertriebenen oder oder geschönten Zahlen, was sie denn.
Da eigentlich haben und auf Basis dieser Zahlen wurde dann eben auch erstmal gerechnet oben,
wo man denn jetzt erfolgreich angreifen kann und anfangs funktionierte das ja auch so so halb.
Aber eben dann dann doch nicht nicht so gut und ähm dann
kamen eben dann solche Dinge dazu, dass äh ja jetzt Truppen, von denen die Führung dachte, da wären vielleicht
doppelt so viele Leute eigentlich, wurden dann gegen Stellungen geschickt, wo die Formeln sagten, ja neunzig, 95 Prozent Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit. Jetzt haben
sie aber in Wirklichkeit am Boden nur mit der Hälfte der Truppen angegriffen und äh sind dann halt zurückgeschlagen.
Worten, so jetzt hätten aber haben die Formeln haben wir gesagt, sie hätten eigentlich gewinnen müssen so und melden dann aber jetzt auch nicht zurück
ja, wir haben uns hier jetzt eine blutige Nase geholt, sondern es her halt auch nicht nicht gut aus, wird dann eher gemeldet, na ja äh wir sind hier auf.
Ähm
ja unerwartet großen Widerstand äh gestoßen, haben uns aber heldenhaft vorgearbeitet, haben unglaublich viele ähm Feinde getötet und unglaublich viel Equipment äh zerstört.
Und äh ja sind aber noch nicht durchgekommen. Und normalerweise sieht dann die russische,
eben auch vor, okay, da wird die erste Welle losgeschickt und,
die, wenn die erfolgreich ist, dann schickt man halt
die zwei hinterher, wenn die nicht erfolgreich ist, schickt man eben eigentlich nicht die Zweite hinterher, sondern überlegt sich dann was Neues. Aber da ja die erste Welle gemeldet hat, äh sie ist hat so große Erfolge erzielt, hat man halt.
Jetzt an die zweite Welle hinterhergeschickt, um jetzt ja das den Erfolg zu verstetigen und
und den Gegner endgültig zu bezwingen, aber in Wirklichkeit sind die halt wieder dann äh gegen eine Wand äh gelaufen und äh alle dahin gemetzelt worden und.
So kam's dann vor, dass erst nach drei oder vier Versuchen.
Manche Städte sind dann fünf Mal erobert worden. Ich glaube bei Piskey war das der Fall, wo irgendwie ständig vermeldet wurde, ja und jetzt haben wir den Ort erobert und das erklärt sich dann eben auch äh so, dass.
Dann eben und das fiel dann irgendwann auch den russischen Mehlbloggern auf, dass äh ständig dieselben Orte offenbar erobert äh werden,
und äh so erklärt sich dann schon mal ganz gut, dass die Spitze.
Je weiter sie von der Front entfernt ist umso weniger weiß, was da eigentlich überhaupt äh.
Los ist so ne und äh dass sie halt ständig die falschen Zahlen in ihre Formeln einsetzen und so dann zu völlig falschen,
Ergebnissen kommen, wo man dann denkt, sind die jetzt bekloppt, wieso rennen die halt ständig gegen diese äh Verteidigungsstellung ein und holen sich eine blutige Nase und äh der Grund dafür ist nicht, weil jetzt die Russen verrückt sind oder irgendein Kommandeur,
da jetzt ist, der unbedingt jetzt hohe Verluste äh gerne hätte, sondern weil einfach ihre Formeln äh und die ganze Informationslage äh eigentlich das vernünftig erscheinen
lassen, äh was aber in Wirklichkeit total totaler Wahnsinn ist. So und ähm.
Das ähm ist natürlich es ist schon mal ein Riesenproblem und es ist aber ähm und.
Was aber noch noch schlimmer ist, ist das eigentlich äh Russland keine Chance hat.
Dieses Problem wirklich zu beseitigen, weil das eben
Vom untersten Soldaten äh quasi bis äh zu Putin rauf reicht, auf jeder Ebene wird geschönt und gelogen und ähm eigentlich müsste das dann eben von von oben.
Kommen äh und man müsste das gesamte System umkrempeln, aber wo sollen denn jetzt,
sage mal, die Agenten der Korruptionsbekämpfung dann kommen, wenn das System so durch und durch korrupt ist, äh dass man eigentlich nicht wirklich weiß, wo man da ansetzen kann.
In dem Zusammenhang fiel mir dann auf, dass Krieg dann offensichtlich so etwas ist. Äh.
Was dann eben auch mit Lügen irgendwo am Ende des Tages aufräumt, weil du kannst eben.
Dir Erfolg nur bis zu einem gewissen Grad zusammen
Lügen, ja oder für eine gewisse Zeit. Aber am Ende kommt dann eben die Stunde der Wahrheit, wie in oder wo du dann einfach zum,
gezwungen bist und wo ja ähm alle Erfolge vorher, die du gemeldet hast oder alles, was was du dir zusammenphantasiert hast äh vorher dann einfach mal den Realitätsabgleich nicht nicht überlebt.
Und das ist,
sagen fand ich so einen ja einfach eine interessante Erklärung, warum die Russen scheinbar so an an vielen Stellen so dämlich agieren und warum.
Sie wahrscheinlich auch nicht die Wände.
Hinbekommen, weil sie nicht einfach jetzt plötzlich äh plötzlich die Wahrheit äh so äh ähm ja äh auf auf allen Ebenen, auf einmal äh ähm.
Ausbricht und und und alle sich alle jetzt anfangen wahrheitsgemäß zu berichten und und die Korruption aufhört und so. Es wird sicherlich ein Stück weit den Effekt haben, weil einfach,
ja Leute äh also auch die Russen bemerken, wenn irgendwas schief läuft und versuchen natürlich gegenzusteuern und
Natürlich wird sich da werden, sich da auch Dinge verändern, aber eigentlich haben die Russen allein schon aus dem Grund
schon mal keine guten Chancen die Wende hinzukrieg.
Diese Lügengeschichten, das geht ja äh noch ein bisschen weiter, also es gab ja zum Beispiel diesen Fall der Stadt äh also Stadt, das ist nicht so das Orts Dowinke, südlich von äh Issium, wo
Die Russen an ihre Kommandeure die Einnahme dieses Ortes gemeldet haben, den aber gar nicht eingenommen hatten und ähm.
Dann über einen Zeitraum von zwei Monaten.
Ganze Zeit versucht haben, ihn dann trotzdem einzunehmen, weil sie ja schon als Eingenommen gemeldet haben und immer wieder Truppen reingeschickt haben, die immer wieder niedergemetzelt wurden von den Ukrainern. Ähm das ist ähm auch nochmal so ein Ding,
gibt auch die Geschichten, dass diese ganzen Trainings für die mobilisierten,
durchgeführt wurden, sondern da würden dann einfach Fotos gemacht. Da machen sie so ein bisschen Foto-Op
Stellt euch mal so hin, tut mal so, als würdet ihr schießen. So, dann wird das irgendwie fotografiert, denn dann ist das Training auch schon wieder beendet.
Schickt einfach die Fotos mit so hier haben wir alles durchgeführt, alles super äh passt schon,
also die sind einfach die haben einfach nicht die intelligent.
Um wirklich richtige Entscheidungen zu fällen und fällen deswegen am laufenden Meter schlechte äh Entscheidungen, ne. Äh.
Und und auch noch so ein so ein so ein Prinzip ist ein unschönes Prinzip. Hm angenommen.
Du meldest jetzt, äh sagen ehrlich den Zustand, wie Scheiße es an die Ebene drüber ähm.
Dann steht der Kommandeur oder dein dein Chef vor dem Problem, dass er das Ganze jetzt schönen muss und dein Bericht
irgendwie äh ja verschwinden lassen muss, wenn er nicht schlecht dastehen
äh will. So das heißt, allein dadurch äh.
Dass du jetzt deinen Vorgesetzten in Bredouille bringst mit einem schlechten Bericht. Das alleine führt auch schon dazu, dass quasi Chef sagen, die, die ja auch.
Natürlich Cover your S äh äh fahren, dass sie am liebsten auch nur positive Berichte von
der unteren Ebene überhaupt entgegennehmen, um eben selber sauber dazustehen und dir sagen sogar wieso, hier meine Untergebenen haben alle gemeldet, alles tipp
alles super gelaufen so ja.
Also nein, nach dem Motto, wer schreibt, der bleibt und äh eben am besten keine schlechten Nachrichten überhaupt auch nur entgegennehmen, weil äh ja man eben sonst in die Bredouille kommt,
Und äh ja, das ist sicherlich nicht sage mal.
Unterschiedlich aus stark ausgeprägt auch in verschiedenen äh Bereichen aber ich glaube es erklärt insgesamt ganz viele wirklich irre und komische Dinge, die da äh die Russen angestellt.
Haben. Ja ähm kommen wir zum Winter.
Ja, kommen wir zum Winter, Winter äh das Coming hat's schon äh gesagt, dass es halt jetzt äh also es gilt
vor allem jetzt eben für die noch sehr umkämpften Gebiete ein bisschen weniger für diesen Südteil und speziell für die Krim, weil dort ist es halt auch einfach generell noch mal wärmer und die Situation anders, aber
grundsätzlich
sind wir eben jetzt in dieser Matschsaison angekommen. Es regnet sehr viel, das Wetter ist also generell schon mal schlecht und wenn viel Regen ist, dann bewegt sich da auch nicht so viel
der Boden ist halt sehr lebenhaltig und sehr
schmodderig, da bleibt dann irgendwie alles auch drin stecken, das ist natürlich schlecht, wenn du Vorstöße machen möchtest, insbesondere mit schwerem Gerät über unbefestigte Straßen
aber wenn der Winter kommt und die Temperaturen dann wirklich unter null absinken, dann wiederum friert alles zu und die Situation
ändert sich nochmal neu und dann im Februar geht das Ganze dann wieder in die andere Richtung. So, wie wir das ja auch schon gesehen haben, als der Krieg losgegangen ist.
Ja, also generell, genau, kann man erstmal festhalten, diese Vor- und Nachwinterphasen bevorzugen erstmal den Verteidiger.
So, weil eben sich der Verkehr auf befestigte Wege und Straßen beschränkt, die.
Relativ einfach äh verteidigt werden können, so. Aber schon sagt es, in dem Moment, wo alles zufriert,
werden die Felder wieder befahrbar und teilweise auch die Flüsse einfach überquerbar. Das heißt, da tut sich auf jeden Fall schon mal eine Offensivoption grundsätzlich auf für beide Seiten
natürlich. Plötzlich wird Bewegung äh wieder möglich, äh sodass wir erstmal davon ausgehen können, dass es.
Wahrscheinlich auch Bewegung geben wird, dass sich beide Seiten jetzt auch schon genau darauf vorbereiten. Aber dann ist natürlich noch die die weitere interessante Frage so, wen,
bevorzugt denn jetzt der der Winter eigentlich äh wird der oder wer wer wird stärker durch den durch den Winter äh beeinträchtigt. Also erstmal,
jetzt gesagt Ukraine durch den Schlamm äh beziehungsweise
Offensiven durch den Schlamm werden jetzt erstmal erstmal schwieriger, aber gleichzeitig natürlich auch die Logistik äh wird
dann dann schwieriger und gerade auch die Russen, wenn die sich, wie wir vorhin schon erwähnt haben, teilweise verteilt haben und
teilweise eben gut das triffte beiseiten zu, dann mit Zivilfahrzeugen auch, Matschwege entlang fahren müssen und so, also logistisch
wird es wird es schwieriger und erstmal die Seite, die sowieso schon logistische Probleme,
äh hat. Äh für die wird's wird's jetzt nicht besser, sondern äh die hat noch weniger Luft nach unten.
Und ähm ein weiteres Merkmal natürlich für den Winter ist, wenn du dich, wie das jetzt der Fall ist,
eben überwiegend im Freien in irgendwelchen Stellungen und und und Löchern äh hausen musste und natürlich draußen rumlaufen und auf Patrouille gehen musst. Ähm.
Dann bist du der Kälte ausgesetzt und ähm man geht davon aus, dass ein Soldat ähm der
jetzt einfach nur in dieser Kälte, um nur zu zu überleben einfach mal einen erhöhten Kalorienbedarf hat
zwischen ja 3tausend und 4000 Kalorien am Tag einfach nur äh zum Überleben
und ähm wenn das jetzt dann auch noch ja.
Im Kampf ist, also du dann auch noch rumrennen musst oder nach nach vorne und oder marschieren musst oder Sachen schleppen und
beladen. Ähm ja, dann kann sich das noch mal bis zu verdoppeln. So und dann ist es aber so, dass selbst bei optimaler Versorgung
du nicht mehr als 6000 Kalorien aufnehmen kannst, aber davon können die Russen teilweise nur träumen. Ähm.
Das heißt, allein schon jetzt,
äh die Ernährung oder genügend Nahrungsmittel äh zu zu haben oder nicht genügend Nahrungsmittel zu haben, ist im Winter noch mal ein deutlich verschärftes Problem.
Dann auch noch dazukommt ist.
Dass äh natürlich gute Kleidung äh oder umgekehrt schlechte Kleidung dann auch noch mal den Kalorienbedarf vergrößert. So, das heißt äh schlechte Kleidung und zu wenig
Kalorien zu wenig Nahrung äh verschlimmern die Situation nochmal zusätzliches, das,
addiert sich und dann äh leben die Leute von ihrer Substanz
also verlieren dann einfach auch noch isolierende Fettschichten, die dann verzehrt
werden vom vom Körper, was natürlich auch nicht hilfreich ist im Winter, also so ein Dreifach-äh-Effekt äh.
Und es sieht halt schon so aus, dass ja, die Russen einfach was,
Versorgung mit Nahrungsmitteln angeht, was die Qualität der Kleidung äh angeht. Ähm.
Ein größerer Teil der Truppe da einfach Defizite hat und diese Truppe wird
einfach leiden, selbst ohne allzu große Einwirkung äh durch durch das durch den Gegner. Ähm.
Wird also voraussichtlich der der Winter nochmal die Kampfkrampf äh der Ukrainer.
Relativ äh zu der der Russen vergrößern. So, das ist also auch eigentlich etwas, was wir erwarten können.
Ja also mit anderen Worten ähm der Winter äh.
Wenn man wenn man das eben auch auch vergleicht, da war ja,
ob's ja auch immer ja der der russische Winter und der ist ja bisher immer allen Invasoren äh zum Verhängnis äh geworden, nur in dem Fall, also es ist nicht so, dass der Winter jetzt magisch
die Russen äh äh bevorzugt oder bevorteilt, sondern
bevorteilt halt derjenigen denjenigen, der besser auf den Winter vorbereitet ist und zum Beispiel damals im Winterkrieg gegen Finnland waren das zum Beispiel ganz klar, die Finnen, die da äh erstmal vom vom Winter äh
bevorteilt äh wurden und jetzt äh sind es eben.
Wahrscheinlich eher die die Ukrainer, die da nochmal einen einen Boost äh durch den Winter erhalten werden oder einen stärkeren Boost oder.
Relativ weniger eingeschränkt werden.
Ja um diesen äh Teil, wie geht's eigentlich den Russen äh so vielleicht abzuschließen, sollte man vielleicht auch nochmal so generell auf die bisherigen Erkenntnisse aus dieser ganzen Mobilisierungsaktion beleuchten.
Das ist ja äh so eine Sache. Also offiziell hat ja Putin auch gesagt, okay, die Mobilisierung ist jetzt abgeschlossen. Ich glaube aber nicht, dass das nach innen tatsächlich bedeutet,
die wirklich abgeschlossen ist und diese Zahl von 300000 Leuten
die ursprünglich mal genannt worden sind, die halt erzielt werden sollen durch diese Mobilisierung.
Das weiß keiner so recht. Es ist klar, dass wohl ein signifikanter Teil der Leute, die dort eben.
Verpflichtet wurden zwangsverpflichtet wurden an die Grenze geschickt wurden und dort äh teilweise auch schon.
Gefallen, verwundet äh ist äh desertiert hat, äh was auch immer oder eben vielleicht auch teilweise noch die Lücken schließt, aber sie treffen halt dort auf eine ohnehin schon angespannte Truppe, die ähm ja.
Große Verluste erlitten hat. Es gibt immer wieder Berichte von Bataillonen, die halt einfach komplett
aufgelöst wurden ja wovon 2.5 nochmal 50 übrig bleiben
überhaupt gar keine Strukturen sind, in die man wirklich zuverlässig reinkommen kann und äh es gibt halt auch immer mehr Berichte über konkrete Konflikte. Nicht nur so zum Nachteil mobilisierten, sondern auch zum Nachteil der der Truppen, an dem sich halt einfach
bestimmte Gruppen einfach äh vollkommen gegen ihre Kommandeure äh stellen und dort äh richtig Alarm machen. Es gibt auch Berichte von.
Vorfällen, wo halt dann Streit ausbricht unter den mobilisierten teilweise dann auch so ethnische Konflikte auf ähm poppen und äh gab's ja diesen einen Fall, wo irgendwie,
zwei wissen wir ganz genau aus welcher Region, aus irgendeinem zentralasiatischen äh Region dort einfach dreißig Leute abgeknallt haben und so ne Sachen, ne.
Ich glaube nicht, dass jetzt hier noch viel ähm Druck aufgebaut werden kann, weil der Widerstand natürlich auch in Russland steigt, ne, dadurch dass jetzt die,
Leute sterben und in äh zu Hause anrufen, wenn sie überhaupt noch ein Smartphone haben und von schlechten
Bedingungen berichten, gibt ja diese ganzen mitgeschnittenen Telefongespräche, wenn man da mal so reinhört, ist also wirklich super gruselig entsprechend gibt's dann auch einen Widerstand von den Angehörigen, Müttern,
Ihr Frauen et cetera, die dort versuchen, auf die Behörden einzuwirken, wahrscheinlich meistens ohne viel Erfolg, aber
in der Summe äh rumort es halt zusätzlich.
Ganz davon abgesehen, was wir ja schon mal besprochen hatten, dass also da immer noch Fluchtbewegungen sind und Leute versuchen sich eben dem Zugriff des Staates zu entziehen.
Ähm das nimmt halt Ausmaße an, dass die Leute also wirklich da von der Straße weg rekrutiert werden, auf ihren Arbeitsplätzen
aufgelauert wird oder ja auch sozusagen Mobilisierung als Bestrafung ähm eingesetzt wird.
Diese Wagnergruppe rekrutiert offenbar immer noch massenhaft aus Gefängnissen, das heißt, man holt halt einfach Leute, die.
Wieso was weiß ich, 25 Jahre äh Knast haben und dann da irgendwie eine Gelegenheit sehen, sich vielleicht irgendwie äh zu befreien, was natürlich Quatsch ist, die dort zum Einsatz kommen. Das sind aber alles keine Qualitäts
Truppen so, ne? Und das ist ähm etwas, was äh einfach zunehmende Maße für
Unruhe sorgt, insbesondere auch in diesem ganzen Supporter-Bereich, ne. Das ging dann schon so weit, dass also sogar gegen diese Müllblogger, die ja das ganze Geschehen sehr viel feiner äh beobachten, du hattest es ja schon erwähnt, ne, die dann,
Alle ja alle pro Russland sind und pro Militäreinsatz sind und dann versuchen dieses Geschehen zu begleiten, aber natürlich auch mitbekommen
äh tatsächlich passiert und ja, dass die dann äh auch eine Teilöffentlichkeit aufmachen, die dann wiederum Putin gar nicht so in den.
Kram passen. Teilweise wird da probiert, der hat dann irgendwie Billblogger zu sich eingeladen und die da irgendwie ruhig zu stellen, aber
Großen und Ganzen werden die auch teilweise auch schon unterdrückt und äh verschwinden dann auch einfach mal bestimmte Blogs einfach so mir nichts dir nichts und keiner weiß, was mit den Leuten dann
passiert ist.
Ähm ich meine diese Mobilisierung ist ja ähm.
Entscheidender Faktor dessen, was man so schön Kräfte, Generierung oder Forst Generation äh nennt im Militärjargon und.
Dazu gehört halt natürlich erstmal Leute zu rekrutieren und sie dann auszustatten.
Entsprechende Ausrüstung, die Sie.
Brauchen und sie ausbilden erstens diese Ausrüstung zu benutzen, die ihr natürlich teilweise auch doch hoch spezialisiert und technisch ist,
man auch reparieren und instandhalten muss und äh ja also das ist ähm,
einen Punkt und dann eben auch,
Einheiten, äh die man dann irgendwo eingliedert und dann eben zum Funktionieren bringt, zusammen mit
anderen Einheiten. Das ist halt schon eine komplexe Maschinerie, die man, die man da aufbaut, also Kräfte generieren ist halt ein komplexer Vorgang
und wenn man jetzt.
Sich sich das Ganze anguckt, dass das Ergebnis, wenn jetzt diese 220.000 bisher mobilisierten Stimmen dann.
Sieht das Ganze aus wie thu little too late. Zu wenig zu spät. Ähm.
Weil äh bei der Intensität im Moment, wie gesagt.
Davon ausgehen, dass Größenordnungen von 500 bis 800 rechnet man mal weil.
Man jetzt sagt, okay, Ukraine übertreibt, selbst wenn wir nur von 300 ausgehen. Ja, am Tag äh Soldaten, die die Russen jetzt.
Ja die bei den Russen fallen, die ausfallen durch Tod.
Ähm dann ist eine relativ niedrige äh Zahl nochmal Faktor zwei irgendwo ähm.
Die man dann an Verletzten hat, die dann entweder teilweise oder auch dauerhaft äh vielleicht äh ausfallen. Das heißt, wir sind da schon mal dann in der Größenordnung von tausend.
Jetzt ganz konservativ am Tag, die irgendwie verloren äh gehen und dann nimmt man noch diejenigen dazu, die dann durch jetzt Krankheiten und durch Kälte und durch die Sektion und
äh ja einfach Erschöpfung äh wenn man bei sie zu lange im Kampf äh sind oder psychische Probleme ausfallen,
dann äh ja sind eben, ich sage mal 1tausend bis 1500 am Tag ähm wahrscheinlich eher konservativ geschätzt, was sich dann auf 30 bis 45.000 im Monat
addiert an Leuten, die irgendwie ja ersetzt werden müssen und wenn ich wenn man dem jetzt die 220.000 mobilisierten entgegensetzt, dann ja äh.
Ist das nicht.
Geeignet diese Zahl, um überhaupt nur auf die Zahlen zu kommen, äh mit der Russland den Krieg begonnen hat anfangs, ja also äh.
Das äh schon mal, dass es heißt, äh Russen
schaffen es gerade vielleicht im besten Fall ihre Stärke zu halten. Im schlimmsten Fall,
ähm ja bauen sie sogar äh stärker ab,
als sie in der Lage sind aufzubauen. Während offensichtlich bei den Ukrainern äh das Ganze äh deutlich besser
funktioniert und sie in der Lage sind ganz offensichtlich
Kräfte aufzustellen, die dann zu relativ komplexen, offensiven in der Lage äh sind, die gut miteinander kämpfen und die eben gut.
Motiviert äh sind und mit einer mit einer guten Moral so. Mit anderen Worten ähm die relative Stärke der Ukraine,
über der Stärke der Russen steigt halt weiter an. So.
Also alleine nur aus jetzt, eben Mobilisierung und Kräfte generierungs äh Aspekten ähm.
Wobei die Russen wahrscheinlich nicht alle sofort auch an die Front geschickt haben, sondern man auch davon ausgehen kann, dass ein Teil der Truppen äh zumindest auch eine.
Halbwegs brauchbare Ausbildung und Ausrüstung erhält. Also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass es alles nur Schrott,
aber äh wie viele das betrifft, ist halt unklar und auch noch mal zu der zu der Lügen äh äh Geschichte teilweise.
Scheint es auch so zu sein, dass manche Truppen offiziell gar nicht an der Front sind.
So Aussicht jetzt der russischen Führung, weil.
Weder bürokratischer Fuck-Up oder auch äh ja man Geld nicht zahlen will oder wie auch auch immer. Das heißt Gruppen, die an der Front sind
gelten aus russischer Sicht äh noch irgendwo in Ausbildung befindlich.
Und kriegen halt deswegen zum Beispiel gar keine Frontzulage, was weswegen sich die Leute dann halt aufregen und können dann natürlich auch unter Umständen logistisch gar nicht berücksichtigt werden, wenn sie dann ausrechnen, wie viel Material brauchen sie denn
um die dort befindlichen Truppen zu versorgen und äh Sie haben gar nicht die
die wirklichen Zahlen, dann kommt natürlich auch zu wenig an. Selbst äh wenn es planmäßig läuft, weil es halt nicht tut
Also ja äh ich denke mal das es so aussieht.
Dass das, was immer jetzt mobilisiert wurde wahrscheinlich nicht ausreicht und dass ja
war eigentlich mehr mobilisiert werden müsste, aber mit Ausrüstung und Ausbildung äh scheint.
Das da eben auch.
Enge Grenzen zu geben, sodass äh ja äh das das Spiel auch die Mathematik hier im Moment nicht gerade äh in Russlands zu Russlands Vorteil ähm.
Aussieht.
Ja jetzt äh.
Stellt sich natürlich auch so ein bisschen grade die Frage, was braucht denn jetzt die Ukraine noch, um wirklich diesen.
Feldzug zu Ende zu führen. Ich denke wir sind so beide so ein bisschen auch äh an dem Punkt angelangt, wo wir sagen das Ding kann gewonnen werden.
Ukraine ist einfach auf einer Dreiektorie.
Wo sie generell, vorausgesetzt, dass sie weiterhin die äh entsprechende Unterstützung erhält, also vor allem die Versorgung, Munition und Waffen.
Aber natürlich auch die sonstige logistische Unterstützung und worüber wir noch gar nicht gesprochen haben auch äh.
Die äh Veränderung von weiteren Angriffen auf die Infrastruktur, ne? Das ist äh Thema, was wir hier so ein bisschen hinten angestellt haben, muss man natürlich auch nochmal erwähnen, dass äh jetzt auch grade gestern.
Am 15. nochmal große.
Also eine Angriffswelle geflogen wurde von den Russen sind mittlerweile sehr viel mehr.
Fege Luftabwehrsysteme in der Ukraine eingetroffen und im Einsatz sowohl die von uns hier ausführlich mal vorgestellten Iris-Systeme als auch die Nasanssysteme und viele andere
andere Systeme auch noch, die von allen möglichen Partnern
aus Europa bereitgestellt wurden und den USA. Trotzdem kommen halt immer wieder Messers durch und das ganze Energieversorgungssystem, insbesondere Stromnetz, aber eben auch teilweise die Wasserversorgung, Heizungsversorgung
sind vielen Städten und vor allem auch in Kiew äh ja enorm unter Druck und es gibt halt Blackouts, es gibt
äh wenig Stromversorgung, teilweise eben auch keine Wasserversorgung.
Zum Beispiel geschildert. Also das ist natürlich auch eine logistische Bedrohung, wenn das Land natürlich keinen Strom hat, dann kann's irgendwie auch keinen Krieg führen.
Und ähm es scheint nicht so einfach zu sein, die zerstörten Systeme, insbesondere die Verteilungsstationen, die Russland wohl bevorzugt angreift, ähm zu ersetzen, weil einerseits.
Technisch sehr aufwendig ist. Andererseits ist aber auch die Technologie teilweise gar nicht gibt, weil das russische.
Das russisch geprägte Stromnetz, das sowjetische System wie Strom verteilt wird. Anders ist als in Europa
teilweise äh zum Einsatz kommen und einfach diese Technik so ohne Weiteres nicht gibt auf der Shave, dass man sagt, oh hier
kaputt, kein Problem weg Bulldozern, schließen wir alles wieder an, läuft wieder, ne? So an die äh das ist schon alles relativ komplex und das kann ich im Einzelnen überhaupt gar nicht.
Einschätzen. Also die Ukraine ist unter Druck, gar keine Frage, aber äh sie brauchen natürlich auch Unterstützung und
Bei Luftabwehrsystem ist es relativ klar. Man will natürlich verhindern, dass Russland noch weiterhin die Ukraine schwächt.
Aber auf der Angriffsseite ähm stellt sich halt immer noch die Frage, was können die westlichen Länder eigentlich noch bereitstellen, was äh wirklich dabei hilft, jetzt diesen Krieg zu beenden und da,
diese Diskussion um die Leopardpanzer, wo ich bisher noch keine guten Antworten gehört habe, warum eigentlich.
Systeme in Ukrainern vorbehalten werden, aber sicherlich auch noch ein paar andere Systeme.
Ja ähm wir hatten bei den also bei den Panzern
ist es mir ist es mir auch so ein bisschen unklar, so meine Vermutung ist, dass man ja einerseits so ein bisschen die logistischen.
Aufwand scheut, dann, dass man Angst hat, dass ähm,
ja äh die Panzer vielleicht dann in russische Hände fallen, dass das nicht nicht gut äh aussieht
oder das die Ukraine dann zu schnell gewinnt äh so äh oder dass das eben Bildern dann von deutschen Kampfpanzern äh der russischen Propaganda dann nochmal schaden, also ist so eine seltsame Kombination. Mir ist es mir ist es auch nicht auch nicht
so ganz klar äh plus, dass man das vielleicht auch.
Nochmal als Drohung in der Hinterhand äh halten möchte nach dem Motto, wenn Russland jetzt zu sehr eskaliert, dann machen wir das doch.
Und Ähnliches schien ja auch für diese Attackes äh zu gelten, also diese.
Kurzmittel, also diese ich sage mal kurz strengen Raketen mit größerer Reichweite, so könnte man sie vielleicht.
Äh äh bezeichnen, die.
Ja auch im Prinzip zu Heimas äh gehören hm also derzeit haben,
Wir äh bekommt die Ukraine offiziell nur diese GML.
RS oder wie sie auch dann äh werden sie auch gerne genannt. Gimmlas äh so mit,
der sie dann ja sechzig, achtzig Kilometer äh weit.
Ziele treffen können, die nicht so supergroße Sprengköpfe haben, die ja aber immerhin geeignet waren ja, ähm diese Antonowski-Brücke zu durchlöchern und ähm.
Ja, aber äh das ist natürlich das ist schon mal ein ein eine gute Reichweite. Ähm.
Die sind halt erstmal.
Schlecht von normalen Mehrfachraketenwerfern äh zu unterscheiden oder auch von Artillerie äh Granaten, ja das das vielleicht schon schon eher, aber ja, jedenfalls äh ist es der russischen
Luftabwehr bisher nicht gelungen auch diese in nennenswerter Zahl zu bekämpfen, wenn wenn überhaupt
so ja, die kommen durch, ja und bei den größeren Attacks,
ist es so, die dir auch immer gefordert werden, gibt der Ukraine doch endlich auch diese 300 Kilometer Reichweite äh Raketen mit größerem Sprengkopf ähm.
Da ist eine erstmal so, dass halt die Dinger dann pro Pot nur eine so eine Fette verschießen können
äh
eben ähm ja sechs äh Gimmler und auch vom Preis her verhält es sich ungefähr so, dass so eine Attacks rund eine Million Dollar kostet
und so eine Rakete eher so zwischen ja um die hundert1fünfzig-, 200.000 in der in der Gegend
Das heißt, man kann jetzt halt für eine Attackims kann man so sechs bis acht Gimmler ähäh liefern und,
sind natürlich auch
und haben eine größere Radarsignatur und wenn sie weiter fliegen, dann sind sie auch länger in der Luft und äh werden dann eben früher geortet und die Vermutung
mal jetzt auch, dass halt diese ähm von der russischen Luftabwehr besser bekämpft.
Werden können und es sich dann auch eben,
lohnt äh so eine S300 Abwehr Raketel gegen äh die eine Million kostet zu starten. Da ist die.
Economy äh ganz ganz gut, äh wenn man vor allem wenn man dann auch trifft, während selbst wenn so eine S300 gegen.
Gegen die äh Gimmlers helfen würde, äh wäre die wahrscheinlich trotzdem auch,
teurer ja äh und äh wir wissen halt äh dass dass es halt nicht geht, dass die anderen warten.
Der Grund, warum äh die USA keine Attacks äh liefert, ist, dass sie einfach annehmen, dass sie nicht
so effizient sind und nicht so viel
äh liefern, zumal ich dann mit ich sage mal sechs oder acht
äh Gimmlern kann ich halt sechs bis 8 unabhängige Ziele äh äh bekämpfen, wobei sie in der Regel mindestens Double oder Triple Tab äh machen, aber habe ich trotzdem noch zwei bis dreimal so viel
unabhängige Ziele, die ich bekämpfen kann für dasselbe Geld äh wie mit einer ähm Attackcoms oder so. Aber.
Hm das ganze Kalkül könnte sich in dem Moment ändern, wenn äh wiederum,
ist der Ukraine gelingt, die russische Flugabwehr äh entsprechend.
Zu dezimieren, äh dass die halt dann nicht mehr in der Lage sind äh auch Attackcams,
zu schießen und dann könnte es durchaus sein.
Dass sie eben das das Kalkül äh auch verändert. Bis dahin scheint es so zu sein, dass es die Amerikaner oder der Westen ganz geil geschafft hat, den Russen das Ganze zu verkaufen als na ja ähm,
Wir liefern die nicht, äh weil äh ja wenn wir nicht eskalieren wollen, aber in Wirklichkeit liefern sie die nicht, weil die nicht so geil sind grade, aber äh sie als,
das trotzdem als Drohung in der Hinterhand äh behalten können. Das fand ich nochmal so eine,
interessante These, an der, glaube ich, äh durchaus was dran sein könnte.
Also so oder so ist äh wäre schon gut, wenn die Ukrainer halt mehr Long-Range ähm Niss
äh hätte, weil sie dann einfach die Command und Controlcenter angreifen konnte, insbesondere auf der Krim.
Man wird sehen, also letztlich zeigt sich ja die Ukraine extrem modern in der Art und Weise, wie sie dann das Gerät auch zum Einsatz bringt.
Hatten da glaube ich auch schon mal ein paar Beispiele äh genannt, insbesondere was so die Abstimmung mit Drohnen betrifft, wo also dann auch schon so normale Schützenpanzer im Prinzip wie Artillerie
verwendet werden, indem dann halt einfach immer wieder äh korrigiert wird, das heißt der Schützenpanzer schießt nicht direkt.
Auf ein Ziel, wie es eigentlich normalerweise so gedacht ist für so einen Schützenpanzer mit den relativ kleinen äh Munitionsdurchmessern
sondern zielt eben tatsächlich auf weitere Ziele, schießt also quasi höher in die Luft und wird dann über die Drohnen Operators entsprechend korrigiert, sodass man eben auch
das quasi wie so 'ne so 'ne Miniatillerie verwenden.
Was da so indirekt fire mit.
Genau, das ist dann halt äh mit einem Gerät, was eigentlich so dafür nicht äh unbedingt gedacht ist und ähm was ähnliches habe ich ähm berichtet gesehen, äh machen Sie auch mit diesem Gepardpanzern.
Ja sozusagen Luftabwehrpanzer äh sind und dieses extrem schnell sich drehende Radarelement haben, ne.
Vielleicht die Bilder so das dreht sich da die ganze Zeit, macht Radar Radar Radar und wenn da halt irgendwas kommt, dann kann sich eben auch dieser Turm des Gepards sehr schnell drehen.
Aber was äh Ukraine teilweise machen, ist, dass sie eben bestimmte Gebiete
versuchen abzusichern, indem sie verstreute Einheiten haben, die mit so unterwegs sind, also mit so tragbaren Flugabwehr äh Kanonen, die man so auf der Schulter trägt.
Und die aber mit diesem Gepardpanzern vernetzen. Das heißt, der Gepard übersieht mit seinem Radar eben diese äh Gebiete.
Meldet dann blitzschnell an diese Einsatzkräfte, dass irgendwo eine Bewegung ist und damit haben sie's wohl schon äh geschafft einmal irgendwie vier Hubschrauber an einem Tag runterzuholen, weil einfach den Gepard, die gemeldet hat.
Aber nicht unbedingt im Range war, den äh abzu,
aber sie dann einfach gesagt haben, okay da hinten ist was, zack, äh kommt mal raus ausm Busch und dann haben die halt innerhalb kürzester Zeit diese äh so ein Manpad losgeschickt und dann ja
mit dem Hubschrauber. Also das sind so die Methoden, mit denen sich die Ukraine da einfach kreativ vorsetzt überhaupt ist das äh so eine Masterclass in digitaler äh Kriegsführung.
Also jetzt nicht im Cyber-Krieg, sondern eben aufm äh realen äh Schlachtfeld. Trotzdem.
Denke ich mal, ist einfach jetzt noch mehr Unterstützung nötig, einfach um den Krieg auch letztlich billiger zu machen. Das ist halt das das Ding, ne? Also das.
So viel Waffen vorenthalten wurden, äh solange hat eigentlich alles nur noch schwieriger gemacht und äh man würde jetzt eben sehr gut daran tun, auf den letzten Metern eher nochmal äh richtig aufzudrehen
USA machen das offenbar. Gestern gab's die Ankündigung, dass die USA nochmal 37 Milliarden US-Dollar äh locker machen wollen für entsprechende militärische Unterstützung
Das ist im Kontext dessen, was sie bisher geleistet haben, nicht wenig, nämlich ungefähr noch mal ähm die Hälfte von dem, was sie bisher schon geleistet haben. Sprich, dann werden sie so auf 1hundert Milliarden
US-Dollar äh Militärunterstützung kommen, das ist schon ja das ist schon relevant, die Größenordnung. Muss man halt sehen, was dabei jetzt rauskommt.
Alles ein Schnäppchen im Vergleich zu sich wenn man sagen die NATO.
Einen Tag in den Einsatz schicken äh würde, da kannst du die Ukraine, Wochen oder Monate lang mit Waffen versorgen, was so einen Tag.
Kampf oder Eingriff von der von der NATO bedeuten.
Gut, jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, was.
Was passiert jetzt? Wir hatten hier vor einigen Sendungen mal die Sendung die dritte Phase genannt.
Und interessanterweise hat der äh wie heißt der Puck Anderson.
Anders Punkt Nielsen.
Anders genau Nielsen, so rum heißt er, ähm.
Jetzt auch so die Begrifflichkeit aufgemacht und gesagt, okay, auch auf seiner Perspektive waren das jetzt bisher drei Phasen, aber jetzt nach der.
Eroberung von Reson sind wir definitiv in der vierten Phase dieses Krieges ähm wobei jetzt noch komplett offen ist, womit diese Phase jetzt gefüllt wird. Also die Ukraine ist jetzt am Zug.
Es sind nicht die Russen, die
vorgegeben, wo das Kriegsgeschehen stattfindet mit dieser kleinen Ausnahme des Kampfgebiet da um um um Bachmutter, aber das kann man glaube ich jetzt erstmal
ignorieren und und der andere Brennpunkt da um um Donetsk, aber das sind eher so lokale Feuer. Damit sind aber keine großen offensiven und keine großen, strategischen Geländegewinne äh verbunden, weil das wird
einfach Russland nicht mehr hinbekommen können. Die Frage ist, wo geht's weiter.
Vielleicht können wir doch noch mal kurz die drei Phasen dann die bisherigen noch mal ganz kurz erwähnen, nämlich Phase eins wäre quasi Schlacht um Kief gewesen, äh wo sich Russland dann zurückziehen musste, die Russland verloren hat
Phase zwei war dann die russische Offensive im.
Wo dann eben auch so Städte wie äh und so eingenommen wurden und sie dann über Monate hinweg mit massiven
Einsatz an Artillerie sich versucht haben, nach vorne zu arbeiten und es nur sehr.
Nur teilweise gelungen ist und die Phase 3 äh war dann,
Sie der bisherige Wendepunkt, nämlich die Gegenoffensive äh erstmal um die
äh Region äh und äh dann die Einnahme von äh Kerstin, wobei äh ja man das ja ruhig zusammen äh zählen kann und.
Interessanterweise eben ja Russland versucht hat äh,
Kerstin äh zu retten und dafür geopfert hat und dann trotzdem Kehrson verloren hat. Das ist vielleicht das Bemerkenswerte. Ja und jetzt eben Phase vier,
und ähm und so ein bisschen.
Ist diese Phase vier jetzt eine, die äh vielleicht schon mal eine Entscheidung bringen könnte, nicht notwendigerweise muss aber quasi so die Ukraine eröffnet.
Jetzt die hat hat jetzt Spiel und könnte jetzt irgendwie das mit Satz und Sieg zu Ende bringen oder.
Eben auch nicht. So und dann geht's halt weiter. Also das sind sozusagen im Moment die die zwei äh.
Wahrscheinlich einen realistischen Möglichkeiten.
Dass äh die russische Front hält oder die russische Front nicht hält. So ähm und äh ja.
Schon äh jetzt die in der in der Sendung immer wieder erwähnt haben,
spricht halt, ja, der Winter und die Lügen und das Problem mit Forst Generation äh und.
Ja insgesamt hohe hohe Verluste äh spricht eigentlich.
Stark dagegen, dass die Russen eine also schließt es fast aus, dass die Russen irgendwie eine Wende.
Hinbekommen können und äh ja äh deutet eigentlich auch eher darauf hin äh dass es erstmal,
ja, das ist bis auf weiteres weiter bergab geht und
dass es möglicherweise jetzt einfach zu,
spät ist äh für die Russen, um wirklich noch eine noch eine Wende hinzubekommen. Also sie müssten dann wahrscheinlich komplett ihre gesamte Gesellschaft, das ganze Land äh auf einen totalen Krieg
einschwören und selbst das würde dann dauern und,
Das ist halt scheint aber auch nicht ohne weiteres äh möglich zu sein gerade. Also wenn
Wende, dann höchstens langfristig, dann kann das irgendwie Jahre dauern und ich glaube aber nicht, dass äh Russland eben jetzt,
noch Jahre hat oder Putin Jahre hat, sondern.
Äh wie das Nielsen eben aber auch schön bemerkt. Ähm.
Man hat jetzt versucht oder versucht jetzt eine Wende.
Herbeizuführen, indem man einige sehr schmerzhafte und teure äh Dinge getan hat oder ja also angefangen.
Der.
Voreiligen Annexionen ukrainischer Provinzen, die nicht von ihnen ganz kontrolliert wurden, was halt sie so ein bisschen auch zum zum Gespött gemacht hat natürlich, was.
Kluger Schachzug war, dann die Teilmobilisierung oder Mobilisierung, die auch für viel Unruhe äh und geringere Akzeptanz des Krieges in Russland.
Ähm verursacht hat.
Dann hat man jetzt diesen neuen Oberkommando oder oder überhaupt mal offenbar einen Oberkommando für das gesamte Geschehen, wobei.
Das ist immer noch unklar ist, wie äh
wirklich in der Lage ist, seine Truppen dort äh zu kommandieren. Dann die erwähnten Raketenangriffe auf die ukrainische Infrastruktur, die international nicht so gut ankommen
und dann Prinzip jetzt auch noch die Aufgabe von Careson, so das alles sind.
Dinge, ja die ähm man jetzt schlucken musste in in Russland und.
Die aber jetzt dann eigentlich was bringen müssen. So jetzt langsam, also wo man dann jetzt auch erwartet, Asi der neue.
Der neue Kommandeur hat jetzt erstmal Tabula Rasa äh gemacht so und hat jetzt erstmal
alles gekriegt, was er sich gewünscht hat so quasi oder was was halt drin war, nämlich unter anderem auch sich aus Kerston zurückziehen zu können, aber jetzt
ist natürlich der Druck da, dass ich irgendwie auch militärische Erfolge äh.
Einstellen und wenn die jetzt auch nur ausbleiben, wird's ein Problem, aber wenn die Ukraine nochmal drauflegt.
So und noch mehr Territorium im größeren.
Umfang äh befreit, dann wird es, wie wir auch schon gesagt haben, spätestens im Frühjahr wahrscheinlich sehr, sehr eng äh werden für Putin, also
Er hat nicht mehr so viel Kapital jetzt jetzt gut, glaube ich, politisches äh Kapital und.
Deswegen ja auch so ein bisschen in der Propaganda der Schwenk ähm also äh Kerston lässt sich halt schon mal ganz schlecht erklären, so selbst.
Wenn man dem den einfachen Leuten nicht.
So dass ja Russland und.
Wieso verteidigen wir das nicht? Wieso haben wir uns da jetzt zurückgezogen, so das passt alles nicht äh zueinander und äh wie können die Ukrainer überhaupt.
Nur äh so einen Widerstand leisten, teils natürlich die Erklärung, dass es gar nicht die Ukrainer sind, sondern natürlich der Westen und in Wirklichkeit
jetzt ja Russland gegen die NATO und die Welt kämpft und die NATO Horden jetzt nur darauf warten äh auch gleich äh weiter.
Zu marschieren.
Aber äh ja diese Logik, also erstmal spielt es keine Rolle, wenn hm.
Einfach ständig nur verloren wird, dann ist das völlig egal, gegen wen da gekämpft wird, wenn man ständig verliert, ja, dann macht das jetzt nicht so
den den den großen Motivationsschub und.
Dann wissen die Leute aber instinktiv auch wieder schon, dass es nicht wirklich die NATO ist, äh die da gegen die sie kämpfen, weil sonst gäb's ja keinen Grund.
Nicht in Polen einzumarschieren oder direkt auch auf NATO-Gebiet
Schläge äh durchzuführen. Also insofern ist das halt auch wiederum klar, dass das nur vorgeschobene Propaganda ist, zumindest bei der äh der Führung ist, ist das halt klar. Das
dass äh die NATO.
Indirekt verwickelt ist, während Russland eben direkt äh verwickelt ist in diesen Stellvertreterkrieg und dass Russland das ja.
Eigentlich auch gerne erstmal so behalten äh äh möchte, so dass sie auch nicht nicht so scharf drauf sind,
äh weil das wäre jetzt kein Problem für die Russen einen Krieg von Zaun zu brechen mit der NATO, wenn sie's jetzt nur wollten, aber ganz offensichtlich wissen sie, dass das eine schlechte Idee
wäre, dass sie das halt, dass sie doch nicht wirklich gegen die NATO kämpfen in der Ukraine. Ja.
Ja die Frage ist, wie geht's jetzt weiter, ne.
Mhm. Also mhm.
Ich äh habe mal gesagt vom vom Gefühl her.
Denkt man immer noch, oh mein Gott, Russland so groß und mit Atomwaffen und.
Eigentlich können die ja nicht so,
verlieren und wenn die nur wollen und irgendwie,
kriegen sie dann vielleicht doch doch die Wende äh hin. So das ist immer so ein bisschen im im Hintergrund so ein,
so ein reines Gefühl und dann kommt es ja auch oft anders, als man denkt, aber.
Die gesamte Logik, die gesamten Zahlen äh so wie wir sie heute ja auch präsentiert haben, sprechen halt dafür äh ja
dass das jetzt, äh dass wir wahrscheinlich schon den Höhepunkt gesehen äh haben oder den den den Wendepunkt.
Gesehen haben äh wobei wir das natürlich, solange der Krieg nicht zu Ende ist, äh werden wir's nicht endgültig wissen, so erst
im Rückblick wird klar sein, wann war eigentlich der Wendepunkt, aber es kann gut sein, dass eben mit.
Ja jetzt und Offensive hm die.
Eine Wende stattgefunden hat und.
Russland einfach sich äh weiter auf dem absteigenden Ast befindet und es jetzt nur eine Frage der Zeit ist, äh wann Russland
gezwungen ist ähm ja den Kampf einzustellen und äh zu verhandeln.
So ernsthaft zu verhandeln. Also das waren ja jetzt auch schon so Signale.
Kam gut, Russland tut ja immer so als äh wollten sie äh immer äh.
Verhandeln, aber waren jetzt erstmal beleidigt, dass die Ziele sozusagen, dass das, was die Ukraine als Vorbedingungen stellen, äh.
Eine Verhandlungsverweigerung äh darstellt, weil es ja komplett unrealistisch äh sei, dass Russland irgendwie das gesamte.
Besetzte Gebiet und Gadi Krim aufgibt, aber.
Genau das ist äh im Moment das Kriegsziel der Ukraine natürlich.
Es ist das Kriegssinn und es wird halt auch in zunehmenden Maße äh äh realistisch beziehungsweise es ist ja auch verständlich. Also es ist ja.
Mehrfach klar geworden, dass einfach Russland ist einfach im totalen Vernichtungsfeldzug
Man muss sich da nur mal irgendwie im lokalen Fernsehen, im russischen Fernsehen ein bisschen umhören, was da äh alles so ideologisch von sich gegeben wird und es ist irgendwie relativ klar. Es herrscht einfach so eine Stimmung des.
Ja, die Ukrainer sind halt einfach, die gibt's halt einfach,
nicht, wo dieser Staat hat, nicht zu existieren und sind irgendwie alles nur Russen, die äh
mental durchgedreht sind und man muss jetzt irgendwie gerade biegen, damit sie merken, dass sie richtige Russen sind und de facto on the ground äh findet halt einfach eine Entvölkerung
statt, um sich dieses Territorien anzueignen, sie dann später irgendwie mit äh Russen zu besetzen. Das ist das, was wir von Anfang an sehen und es gilt einfach nach wie vor
wenn eben Russland aufhört zu kämpfen in der Ukraine, dann ist Frieden und wenn die Ukraine aufhört zu kämpfen äh in der Ukraine, dann
wird es ihre Vernichtung
sein. So und das sind halt einfach ähm die beiden Eckenpunkte, an denen man sich klar machen muss was äh man eigentlich von Russland erwarten kann, nämlich dass sie eigentlich.
Nur sich komplett zurückziehen und das eben auch aus dem Donbass und das auch aus der Krim, weil erst dann wird auch die Ukraine äh Ruhe geben.
Nicht, dass diese jetzt in irgendeiner Form sich jemals auf irgendwas einlassen werden. Die sind einfach viel zu stark und viel zu.
Motiviert, die wollen jetzt dieses Thema ein für alle Mal beenden und da wird man sie auch nicht dran hindern können.
Die werden das jetzt einfach tun, so und äh wir haben nur die Möglichkeit
Das äh zu einem Prozess zu machen, der sich ewig hinzieht. Das ist für uns alle nicht gut und das ist auch einfach für für die Ukraine äh auch ein völlig unakzeptable Situation. Natürlich, aber sie werden sie werden jetzt nicht sagen irgendwie so, oh.
Lassen wir's mal sein, sondern das ist jetzt einfach zu viel
gewesen so. Also so ein Vernichtungsfeldzug, da man kann sich ja kaum vorstellen, wie überhaupt das Verhältnis zwischen der Ukraine und Russland sich jemals in den nächsten zwanzig, 30 Jahren wieder normalisieren
kann.
Wahrscheinlich ja äh wird das äh noch Jahrhunderte äh möglicherweise äh.
Kann gut sein, ja.
Nach nachhängen äh so historisch und.
Was im Moment so ich sage mal gehandelt wird als mögliche ja Lösung oder möglicher Entzustand ähm
des Ganzen ist äh ja eine entmilitarisierte Krim so äh.
Unter ja allerdings ja unter ukrainischer Verwaltung oder mit einem hohen Maß an Selbstverwaltung so, dass scheint so im Moment das Maximum zu sein, äh was grade
im im Westen an an Kompromiss äh gedacht,
und äh ja.
Was die anderen Regionen angeht hm.
Hat ja der der Kampf um die findet ja seit 2014 statt, also die da hat's ja nie wirklich Ruhe gegeben und da sehe ich auch nicht, dass das irgendwie
Ähm.
Ja Ruhe äh geben wird, wenn dort äh die solange dort Russen äh solange Nordrussisches Militär stationiert ist und,
ähm ja also insofern sehe ich im Moment.
Als die wahrscheinlichste Variante, dass spätestens im Frühjahr ähm.
Ja die äh Russen an den Punkt gekommen sein werden, wo sie politisch äh nicht mehr bereit sind den Krieg weiter zu führen oder oder weiter äh.
Die nötigen Ressourcen mobilisieren zu können, um äh militärisch äh dort.
Den Krieg weiterführen zu können. Das ist meine Erwartung und es gibt eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das vorher auch passieren könnte.
Konkrete vierte Phase betrifft, kann man sich natürlich fragen, okay, wo geht's jetzt auch militärisch weiter.
Das ist offen, also auf der einen Seite äh haben wir natürlich jetzt schon noch die
laufende, eine offensiv Bemühung da in Luhansk. Ich denke mal, die werden mittelfristig auch erfolgreich sein äh können mit äh der möglichen Rückgewinnung des Nordens von
Es gibt da nach die Stadt, die jetzt derzeit da im Blickfeld ist, noch eine zweite Stadt, die eine strategische Rolle spielt, Staro Billsk, das ist dann nochmal so hundert Kilometer
Osten und wenn das dann
auch noch mal umkämpft wäre oder vielleicht fällt, dann ist da eigentlich die Verteidigung nicht mehr so richtig zu halten aus meiner Perspektive. Das wird sich zeigen
aber strategisch wichtiger, kann es äh fast sein, eben jetzt in Saarbrücker voranzukommen und vor allem äh dieses Atomkraftwerk wieder zurück in ukrainische Hände zu bekommen. Das wäre sicherlich auch nochmal so ein eine Niederlage, von denen die Russen sich kaum erholen würden, weil dann würden sie eben wirklich dann in die
ähm Krim zurückgedrängt werden und unter Umständen dort dann eben auch äh angegriffen werden.
Viele Fragezeichen, wissen wir alles nicht ähm kann man nur spekulieren.
Und das weiß auch tatsächlich niemand bisher äh so richtig, weil.
Der weitere Verlauf ja davon abhängt auch äh wie sich,
beide Seiten verhalten werden, also äh die Ukraine hat zwar die Initiative.
Aber ich denke nicht, dass Sie jetzt äh.
Sagen äh einfach irgendeinen Plan haben, den sie
jetzt aufbiegen und brechen, versuchen umzusetzen, also an an irgendeiner Stelle, sondern ich rechne damit, dass sie wie bisher
einfach schauen werden, äh wo äh sind,
Schwächen, also dass sie erstmal äh versuchen werden äh weiter Druck zu machen, weiter die Logistik der Russen äh zu stören, weiter
Hauptquartiere äh zu zu beschießen, weiter ja Druck zu machen an der an der Front,
Und ähm also ja, die Russen weiter ab abzunutzen und dass es dann.
Von so Faktoren, wie eben Wetter und wie äh ja äh.
Wo wo die Russen wie viel Kräfte äh konzentrieren oder auch nicht.
Äh konzentrieren. Davon wird es dann auch ein Stück weit abhängen ähm wo die Ukraine dann vielleicht zum.
Ja wo die Ukraine dann selbst Durchbrüche äh erzielen kann und.
Da spielt natürlich eben auch eine eine Rolle, dass offensichtlich die Aufklärung der Ukraine äh immer noch besser funktioniert als die der Russen und äh.
Dass die eben nicht umgekehrt die äh die Ukraine auf ähnliche Art und Weise weich kochen können, beziehungsweise sie versuchen selbst über die Infrastruktur, weil das das Einzige ist, was sie jetzt im Moment
können, so die die Terrorangriffe, aber da zeigt auch die Erfahrung aus vergangenen Kriegen
dass das nicht zum Erfolg äh führt. Es hat noch nie äh wirklich zum Erfolg geführt.
Aus der Luft alleine.
Zu kämpfen, ähm sondern du musst muss halt schon äh brauchst die Truppen äh am am Boden, die auch Erfolge haben und äh indem du.
Trafostationen.
Mit superteuren äh Raketen angreifst, die wahrscheinlich so teuer sind äh wie die äh.
Verteilerstationen, die da getroffen. Äh werden kommst du einfach nicht weit, äh zumal.
Ja äh mir auch die Russen einfach äh.
Nicht wirklich genug Raketen haben. Wir haben jetzt gesehen, dass sie jetzt immer mehrere Tage oder auch eine Woche pausieren müssen, um dann genug.
Äh auf einmal losschicken zu können, um mit der immer besser werdenden ukrainischen Flugabwehr äh klar zu kommen und.
Also sieht nicht gut aus für die Russen.
Belassen wir's vielleicht erstmal äh dabei und schließen den Timer ab.
Ja vielleicht noch äh dann dann ein Ding ist dir aufgefallen, dass jetzt äh das Gerede des Nukleargerede so ein bisschen aufgehört hat äh.
Hat es.
So ähm und das hat vermut.
Nicht nur im Westen, sondern auch im bei Russland.
Ja äh und es hat wohl mehrere Gründe.
Ein Grund ist, weil eben äh unter anderem China und Indien da äh deutliche Ansagen gemacht haben,
Ähm aber ein anderer Grund ist noch ähm.
Die Amerikaner gerade wohl die Situation äh sehr klug nutzen, um äh gerade Gespräche über den Abbau von äh Nuklearwaffen
zu beginnen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast.
Nee, nicht direkt.
Und zwar äh war wohl der Pitch der Amerikaner äh sah wohl so aus.
Dass äh die Amerikaner jetzt an die Russen rangetreten sind und gesagt haben, hey, wie sieht's denn aus.
Eure ganzen Atomwaffen, die euch gerade sowieso nicht weiterhelfen im Ukrainekrieg. Ähm habt da nicht
Lust, äh dass wir gemeinsam ein bisschen reduzieren, dann habt ihr auch Geld frei, um irgendwie.
Mehr für euren Krieg einzusetzen und die Russen äh sind wohl darauf
angesprungen und haben wir gesagt, oh ja, äh lass uns.
Einfach mal reden über den Abbau von Atomwaffen.
Aber wo hast du jetzt diese Information her? Daraufhin habe ich jetzt irgendwie nix. Sind das.
Ja, das.
Diese geheimen Gespräche in der Türkei, die da angeblich gelaufen sein sollen.
Äh ja nicht nur in der Türkei, sondern äh ja ähm also ich weiß gar nicht äh ich habe das aus zwei verschiedenen äh äh Quellen gehört, dass das äh grade wohl
ja, dass man da angefangen hat.
Gerüchteküche, aber wir halten mal fest, äh deine Position ist jetzt äh kein nuklear Krieg nach Weihnachten.
Ja, also sieht im Moment nicht so aus äh als äh.
Würde jetzt äh ja in absehbarer Zeit,
eine nukleare Eskalation erfolgen, wobei natürlich die strategischen Waffen ist nochmal eine andere äh Sache als jetzt die taktischen Atomwaffen, also die Gespräche
gehen wohl nur um äh Belgien in erster Linie um Abbau von strategischen.
Waffen, die definitiv äh ja für den Ukraine-Krieg äh komplett nutzlos äh sind.
Na wir beruhigen.
Zwei, drei kleinere Sachen sollten wir noch äh nachschieben, jetzt wo wir mit dem großen Teil äh durch sind, ähm weil wir da auch glaube ich nicht so viel zu berichten haben, aber ich wollt's dann trotzdem noch mal aufgreifen. Wir hatten uns ja hier auch sehr ausführlich über
Angriff auf Nordstream ähm unterhalten. Auch das ist so ein Thema, was irgendwie in den Medien äh überhaupt nicht mehr so richtig vorkommt
gab nur so eine relativ geheimhalterische Untersuchung der Schweden, wo man nicht so richtig genau weiß, was dabei rausgekommen ist, auch Nordstream selber wollte hier nochmal Untersuchungen machen, aber so richtig zu.
Ergebnissen scheint es bisher noch nicht gekommen zu sein.
Und es gab ja in der Zwischenzeit dann noch diese Unterwasser-Aufnahmen, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir.
Uns zu denen geäußert hatten von der Presse und
da sieht es für mich so aus, also die,
jetzt auch nicht sehr gehaltvoll äh diese diese Aufnahmen und dass die.
Das entscheidende Stück, also da wird wird halt ein Stück von der von der.
Pipeline auch gezeigt, aber diese diese.
Ställe sieht eher so aus, als sei das eine Stelle, wo die Schweden wahrscheinlich.
Ein Stück von dem Rohr abgesägt haben, um das als Beweisstück mitzunehmen, das heißt äh dass sozusagen.
Das entscheidende Ding, wie sie
jetzt die Stelle aus, wo was potenziell gesprengt wurde äh oder geplatzt ist oder wie auch immer ähm das äh ja es davon keine äh Aufnahmen.
Und das Ganze ist ja nach wie vor äh sehr, sehr rätselhaft. Äh die ganze Geschichte.
Also es gibt da auf jeden Fall keine klaren Erkenntnisse. Insofern warten wir da ab
dann äh sollte man vielleicht auch nochmal kurz was sagen zu äh Belaros, weil das jetzt so in den letzten Wochen immer wieder mal hoch äh geblubbert
äh ist, ob es denn irgendwie möglich sei, dass Belarus in irgendeiner Form noch mal in den Krieg eintritt oder dass die Russen nochmal äh eine
eine Offensive auf Kiew oder vielleicht auch auf den äh Westen der Ukraine startet. Ähm.
Es sind immer wieder Berichte äh aufgepoppt von.
Truppenverlegungen nach Belarus. Ähm es gab aber auch entsprechende ähm verlegungsschwere Waffen aus Belarus wiederum in russisches Gebiet. Das ging so hin und her,
mein Take dabei äh ist der, dass ähm,
was wir da sehen, ist halt auf der einen Seite die Russen nutzen die Trainingsmöglichkeiten für ihre mobilisierten Soldaten.
Selber ja kaum noch haben
Ja, das heißt, die benutzen einfach belarussische äh Standorte und vielleicht auch deren Personal um äh eine entsprechende Ausbildung für russische Soldaten vorzunehmen.
Darüber weiß man wenig, aber das äh ist so ein bisschen der Eindruck, den man gewinnen konnte. Ähm auf der anderen Seite äh gibt wohl auch,
Ähm Panzermaterial, andere
et cetera, das ist halt alles irgendwie so da äh in den Norden der Ukraine dann auch eingefahren worden. Also.
Anderen Worten sie bedienen sich da auch einfach auch nochmal aus einem Reservoir, weil sie halt einfach.
Einfach so viele Verluste haben, ja, die Amerikaner meinten ja, sie hätten jetzt irgendwie
Die Hälfte ihres kompletten Panzerbestands eingebüßt so, also von allem, was sie sozusagen äh gelagert haben und wir wissen ja, dass was da gelager.
Noch ist, das ist ja jetzt auch nicht so das Allerbeste, also kann davon ausgehen, dass sie sogar einen Großteil,
brauchbaren Geräts äh verloren haben und dementsprechend,
kann so ein Deal gewesen sein zwischen Lukaschenko und Putin, so nach dem Motto hier, ihr müsst uns irgendwie helfen. Aber ähm.
Zum Kriegseintritt der äh weißrussischen Armee als solcher wird's mit Sicherheit nicht kommen, weil die ist auf der einen Seite auch nicht sehr gut ausgebildet und ausgestattet und auch zahlenmäßig nicht
besonders groß und ich glaube, dass Lukaschenko äh auch äh Fuchs genug ist, um zu wissen, dass ähm ein Kriegseintritt jetzt in den Ukraine-Krieg auch für ihn so viel innere Spannung hervorrufen könnte.
Äh er sich das halt einfach gar nicht äh trauen kann. Also ich denke von Belarus geht jetzt so erstmal keine Gefahr aus.
Er ist ja nicht nicht um umsonst Dienstältester Diktator in Europa.
So oder vielleicht ich weiß nicht ob sogar auf der Welt keine Ahnung aber auf jeden Fall ist er ja irgendwie seit Ende der Sowjetunion. Äh dran äh dort in Belarus.
Ja, da gibt's schon noch in Afrika gibt's nochmal so ein paar, die halten halten schon nochmal ein bisschen länger äh so, aber in Europa ist er auf jeden Fall ziemlich weit vorne und der ist ja auch ein Fuchs,
Ähm
Letzter Punkt vielleicht für die heutige Sendung, aber das muss man jetzt schon nochmal kurz ansprechen, auch wenn das jetzt grade
äh gestern Abend hier so ungefähr jetzt mal so 24 Stunden bevor wir dieser Sendung aufnehmen passiert ist
da gab's ähm Aufregung da ähm.
Der Grenze zur Ukraine auf polnischem Gebiet2 Raketen niedergegangen sind, nicht nur das, sondern die haben auch noch so einen Traktor getroffen, um diese landwirtschaftliches Gerät und dabei zwei Leute getötet.
Da gab's natürlich dann erstmal riesige Aufregung, oh Gott, hier der Russe äh schießt die Polen ab, Artikel 5 muss sofort äh entvogt werden und äh der dritte Weltkrieg beginnt
ganz so schlimm scheint's dann doch nicht gekommen zu sein. Ähm das Ganze ist jetzt noch so im Prozess
so wie es derzeit aussieht, handelt es sich wohl um S 300 Raketen und dabei äh
wohl um welche aus der Ukraine. Also Luftabwehrraketen ähm das Ganze hat halt
stattgefunden, während eben die Ukraine sich versucht hat, gegen diese 1hunderteinfliegenden Misshalts über ganz Ukraine.
Die Flugabwehrsysteme haben da ja auch sehr viel runtergeholt. Fünfundachtzig
Prozent ungefähr war so die Aussage, aber ein paar sind halt doch noch,
landet und es macht jetzt gerade so den Eindruck.
Ja, jetzt mal hier so ganz zurückhaltend formuliert. Es macht gerade so den Eindruck,
ob im Rahmen dieser Luftverteidigungsmission äh ein oder zwei Raketen.
Einen anderen Weg gefunden haben oder vielleicht war das eine auch nur die Luftabwehrrakete, das andere war tatsächlich eine russische Rakete, aber das ist sozusagen im Rahmen dieser Abwehrmaßnahmen zu einer Umlenkung kam und
dann äh das Raketenmaterial, sieben Kilometer von der Grenze entfernt auf polnischem Boden runtergegangen ist.
Also ja, wir haben noch keinerlei.
Auch Informationen wo denn welche Raketen jetzt welchen Weg genommen haben
Aber am plausibelsten ist, äh dass äh da irgendwas vom Norden kam, äh was quasi entlang der polnisch-ukrainischen.
Grenze äh dann flog, möglicherweise auch äh teilweise polnischen Luftraum.
Überflogen hat oder in polnischen Luftraum.
Eingedrungen ist und äh dann entsprechend äh ja ukrainische Luftabwehrraketen, die äh im Prinzip von Süden,
äh kamen, also in Richtung Norden äh leicht in Richtung Nordwesten, denn dann abgefeuert äh wurden äh dann quasi,
zu so einer Art äh Raketen, Luftkampf über der Ukraine polnischen äh äh Grenze stattgefunden hat oder ähm.
Möglicherweise auch im Polnischen Luftraum. Das werden jetzt wahrscheinlich noch dann irgendwann genaue Untersuchungen zeigen,
was denn wo lang geflogen ist, mit welcher äh Richtung, aber ich glaube so kann man.
Wahrscheinlich zusammenfassen, dass es eben ein ja Raketenluftkampf äh über der Grenze gab und dass dabei äh Teile der.
Raketen äh dann oder sprengen Köpfe äh dann auf polnischem Gebiet gelandet sind,
zwei Kuriositäten in dem Zusammenhang äh nämlich äh das einmal gemutmaßt wurde. Ich halte das für für Zufall, dass irgendjemand.
Von den Russen in der in der äh Excel-Tabelle, um eine Spalte verrutscht ist, weil irgendwie
ähm nämlich die Einschlagstelle sehr nah ist äh an Koordinaten, äh wo wenn man irgendwie den Lenkengrad von Kiew und den Breitengrad äh von äh
was war's.
Aber genau anders.
Oder genau andersrum äh nimmt, kommt man genau auf die Einschlagstelle, so dass es dann gemutmaßt wurde, ob dann jemand beim Abtippen eben der Excel-Tabelle um eine Spalte spalte und Zeile verrutscht ist und deswegen
die Raketen dahin flogen, weiß ich nicht, halte ich eher für eine Inzidenz
und die andere äh Sache ist, dass dort halt diese Versorgungsleitung zwischen
also Stromleitungen zwischen Polen und der Ukraine, dass dort eine größere Leitung genau entlang äh läuft und
Wenn man jetzt diese Leitung äh genau,
verlängert auf dieses Dorf, wo das eingeschlagen ist, dann liegt eben der Einschlagort
auch genau äh in der Verlängerung dieser Stromleitung, was wahrscheinlich auch nur Zufall äh ist, aber das waren so zwei Dinge, die halt
noch äh diskutiert worden, das gemutmaßt wurde, dass vielleicht eben diese Hochspannungs
Leitung irgendwo Ziel gewesen sein könnte, dieser Raketen, aber wie gesagt,
alles äh eher unwahrscheinlich beziehungsweise äh hoffe, dass wir dann zur nächsten Sendung äh vielleicht ein bisschen mehr wissen oder auch nicht.
Genau, werden wir sehen. So, dann würde ich es äh jetzt hier mal zum Ende bringen wollen. Ich denke für ein Update.
Jetzt auch, sondern auch schon wieder über zweieinhalb Stunden rübergekommen.
Ja Leute, ähm vielen Dank fürs äh Zuhören und euer äh kontinuierliches Interesse.
An dem Programm,
und ähm ja wir werden uns hier wieder zusammenfinden, wenn's wieder ähm sinnvoll ist, glaube ich, alles äh zusammenzufassen. Manchmal ist das wöchentlich, manchmal äh nicht so oft ähm.
Wie's halt so äh kommt. Wir beobachten auf jeden Fall die News immer sehr ausführlich. Also ich weiß nicht, wie viel Zeit du so pro Tag auf den Krieg äh verwendest. Kannst du das mal so quantifizieren Pam Vilm.
Ja es unterschiedlich aber ich würde sagen so zwischen ein und sechs Stunden.
So je nachdem äh was halt grade ist so.
Ähm ja ich habe dann natürlich schon so meine meine auch favorisiert,
YouTube äh Kanäle und äh Twitterer und Reddit
und dann natürlich,
ja je nachdem versuche ich dann halt auch zu verifizieren und andere Quellen für Informationen zu finden, die dann auf YouTube oder in irgendwelchen Vorträgen äh
äh sind und dann ja Hintergründe mir zu erarbeiten und zu gucken, wie plausibel.
Ist das jetzt und stimmen die technischen Informationen und so und ja, also es kann bisweilen schon recht zeitintensiv sein.
Geht mir ähnlich, also es äh fließt relativ viel rein, weil man ja auch viel beobachten muss. Also man hat so erstmal so einfach so den Newsflow.
Was alles so passiert und manchmal ist es ja auch so, man weiß schon so, okay, jetzt kommt hier wieder diese Meldung,
Da warte ich mal ab, bis ich die zehn mal gesehen habe, bis ich äh glaube, dass da was dran ist. Ne, also wie jetzt zum Beispiel diese.
Angebliche äh anphibische ähm Übersetzung da auf äh den Teil von dieses in diesen Kinbein Split et cetera. Da ist,
sehr viel drüber geschrieben worden und dann muss ich natürlich auch immer so ein bisschen davon abhalten, sofort auf jede Meldung anzuspringen und das zu glauben, weil oft ist es nicht so,
dass ja es.
Einfach nur Fehlinformationen sind oder irgendjemand äh behauptet, einfach mal irgendwas bis hin zu vielleicht auch wirklich gestreuten Informationen jetzt ähm.
Von der ukrainischen oder von der russischen Seite, die so nicht stimmt, aber die einfach so an sich ihren ähm Effekt erzielen sollen.
Und ähm wo ist so ein Gefühl dafür auch entwickeln, was jetzt eigentlich äh substanzielle Information ist und ähm was nicht.
Ja und dann gibt's natürlich eben auch schon so die sag mal eher begeisterten ähm ja pro.
Ukraine, YouTuber, die äh natürlich mit denen manchmal dann so die Begeisterung äh durch,
äh oder wo dann öfter auch mal so die die Hoffnung äh Vater des, des Gedankens äh äh sind und da sind genau eben die Fälle, wo man dann
mal so ein bisschen ja vorsichtig äh sein muss und auf der anderen Seite, was was.
Mir immer so ein bisschen sagen, Schwierigkeiten bereitet oder.
Wo ich versuche das richtige Maß zu finden ist
also die Russen können auf der einen Seite jetzt nicht komplett unfähig sein, ja? Also
So aber auf der anderen Seite gibt's eben diese Fülle von ja,
ähm Bildern äh und Geschichten über,
Probleme und Unfähigkeit bei den bei den Russen. Und das Ganze jetzt da.
Die die Mitte zu finden oder oder wo wo befindet sich jetzt die Realität zwischen diesen sagen wir beiden Bildern zwischen jetzt der man dann sagen zwischen der russischen Propaganda und der ukrainisch
westlichen Propaganda und äh.
Da war jetzt aber das sind die die Grunderkenntnis äh dass äh ja.
Bei den Russen wirklich äh schlimmer ist, als ich in der Vergangenheit gedacht habe und,
letztlich, dass diese diese
Gewinne jetzt der Ukraine in in hieß es ja äh ja in
Erfolgen sehr nah, das war Glück und haben die Ukrainer eine geschickt eine Schwäche der Russen ausgenutzt und so und äh,
ja das wird sich jetzt nicht unbedingt
wiederholen lassen oder das ist jetzt nicht nicht irgendwie Indikator dass es um die Russen wirklich so schlecht bestellt ist, aber jetzt im Zusammenhang eben auch mit mit Kerstin und mit allem was wir heute in der in der in der Sendung
auch noch noch behandelt haben, glaube ich, dass äh ja es den Russen eben wirklich schlecht geht.
Trotzdem, also viel äh Zeitaufwand, insofern würde ich mich auch äh freuen, wenn ihr euch hier in dem Zeitaufwand dahingehend ähm Beteiligten, die mir.
Drüber nachdenkt, den Kanal finanziell zu unterstützen. Wir recherchieren für euch und äh
Lesen all die News, die ihr eigentlich gar nicht lesen wollt und ähm insofern wäre ich ähm für eine Unterstützung des Kanals dankbar. Das findet ihr alles auf äh mit der Ebene ME Slash äh Support.
Und damit äh entlassen wir euch äh wieder mal in die Realität, in die wunderschöne Realität.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.